you
you
um
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive
an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david pacman
he is a baby
[Music]
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
[Music]
there are males most men today yeah male
1 they think and act like a woman they
are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on to
that's raw abortion they think and act
just like a woman a beta male died but
another baby
doesn't because he's a logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pakman
he is a baby
[Music]
david packman
he is a man
david pakman he is a bayonet
[Music]
david patman
he is a baby
david patman
he is
pacman
he is a baby
david packman
he is a baby
david pacman
here's a baby
[Music]
you're not here to communicate i really
appreciate you coming on i'm going to
let you go it's a waste of time to talk
to you we're not communicating you're
actually like because you're asking
questions and you're wasting my time i
like
bizarre
appreciate that i'm coming all right
thank
you
goodbye goodbye
[Music]
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones
is now
very very upset with me
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's going to
beat you pac-man never talked to the new
orleans pac-man's the loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate that dude is gone
ladies and gentlemen
i was telling my children to be it's
happening
they're smarter than you
the evil's
[Music]
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
which is just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's just beyond parody i mean massive
dumps cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody i mean massive
dumps cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going on
[Music]
[Music]
my bags are mangoes
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
seems like a pretty good deal a bag of
mangoes mango aren't mangoes like reebok
seeds
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identified with the
mangoes
[Applause]
the american people
don't want me to be healthy
healthy
[Music]
well welcome everybody we are on what is
the final scheduled january 6th trump
riot house committee hearing and we are
expecting three very powerful and
important elements tonight we will see
if all three come to fruition but the
best assessment that we have based on
publicly available information which we
call news articles are that we will see
three incredible things tonight
number one some of you may remember that
very uh oh hold on a second let me just
block a couple people
already people getting blocked bye-bye
okay there we go bam hammer um first and
foremost
we are going to see outtakes of donald
trump attempting to record the video
telling the writers like that's enough
uh but he's like not really wanting to
say the things they want him to say
because he doesn't really want to
denounce the writers it's pretty pretty
interesting stuff so we're gonna see
outtakes and excerpts of that
gonna be insane if that's part of
today's hearing number two
um
we are going to i don't think it will be
live testimony but we are going to
potentially see testimony of donald
trump's former white house lawyer pat
sipoloni also known as patsy bl
patsy bologna uh which was how the
closed captioning almost universally uh
interpreted
pat sipoloni's name patsy bologna
and uh third we are going to see either
live or recorded testimony of the deputy
national security adviser under scrumps
and that should be extraordinarily
compelling as well so any two of those
three elements would make this arguably
the most interesting of all of the
hearings so far if we got all three of
those it would be absolutely stunning
stuff which is why i'm particularly glad
that you're here
sometimes i'm sort of like indifferent
to whether you're here and then
sometimes i'm like kind of into it but i
actually am thrilled that every single
one of you is here today and we have a
lot of things to go over uh and i don't
even know that i should be delaying from
the standpoint of super chats ben hubert
says beautiful coverage tonight david
sir love that the stream intros keep
getting longer and longer i jam out to
mangoes every time that's a that's a big
one that's uh that's actually one of the
favorites pac-man's a loser oh well okay
alex let's uh let's relax let's not get
let's not get crazy
um
okay where to even start because i have
so many things oh uh actually you know
what i'm gonna wait for that let me do a
couple of let me do some thank yous
first and i just want to allow a few
additional people to join
um from the standpoint of twitch i
already have so many people to thank
okay let's see where we are
blueberry babe bone master nug wrangler
skittle stew with five is eight
nasty questions is nine eso tv with two
subscriptions 10 and 11.
snappy tam number 12 general anubis 13.
herp z
merklist and robot laser party put us at
16 and slingblade triple nine now a
twitch prime member uh for 28 months and
that puts us at 17 right off the bat
also want to say thank you to jason
sickmeyer for gifting a subscription on
my website really appreciate that jason
uh kevin gouldy for gifting a membership
on my website and julie mcintyre's for
the gift uh 17 plus three seven plus
three is zero carry the one and two is
20.
very much appreciate that
liam says have you been following the
british prime minister race shout out to
liz truss aka the aluminum lady i
actually have not i'm behind on a lot of
different things
but i promise
i'm going to get caught up okay let's
get into a couple different things next
viewer town hall okay i'm going to give
the instructions for the next viewer
town hall once and only once
and if anybody misinterprets these
it is it is your fault
uh oh whoa thanks to skittle stew for
dumping in 25 gifted memberships that's
that's insane
also thanks to straight man and
mechanically reclaimed meat already
putting us at 47 incredible okay here's
the instructions the next
viewer town hall
will be
tuesday
july 26th that's this coming tuesday
at 6 00 pm eastern time only on the
pacman live youtube channel
okay
only on the pacman live youtube channel
it won't be on the main channel
it won't be on tick tocks or facebook's
it won't be on instagram
and it will only be it's certainly not
on twitch it will only be on pacman live
if you want to call in
you do it via discord
okay everybody get that
davidpakman.com discord
and if you're a website member you get a
separate priority
way to call in
pacman live it won't be on truth central
pakman live youtube channel only
and um 6 p.m on tuesday and i look
forward to
uh hearing from everybody quite frankly
i think it's going to be great not on
rumble not on any of those other
elements please please please please
david sir more streams love the massive
streams and dumps well listen if we get
to 200 members tonight i will commit to
doing the late stream tomorrow trump's
going to be speaking in arizona tomorrow
night and it's like really early in
arizona so it would be a late east coast
stream but i'm willing to do it i'm
willing to do it we will see
uh dave caldwell thanks for the 20 super
chat very much appreciate that all right
i have another announcement to make
would it be would it be an appropriate
time to make another announcement today
can someone tell me
is this an appropriate time for an
announcement
it's not oh god
okay here's the next announcement this
is a by popular demand
because of the incredibly positive
feedback to when i do
personal finance content like debunking
dave ramsey the right wing nut
okay
by popular demand
we are going to be launching
a personal finance youtube channel where
i will only do
personal finance we will do clips
and they will be personal finance
related we will do calls but i will only
take personal finance questions okay
what i need from you
is eleven thousand seven
what i need from you are suggestions for
what the channel should be called
okay which we need something clever
and
we're not yet sure whether my name
should be part of it because one of the
nice things about this channel would be
that we it can be more than just me and
we can get different personal finance
people in to answer your questions okay
so like someone suggested pac money yeah
that's in the chat already pac money i
get it i get it
but i just don't know
if that's too
narrow
so if you have ideas
email info at davidpakman.com in the
title just put finance channel names
okay
super pac money and i don't know that
that's too different than pac money
it won't be stunks
it won't be make money fast or anything
like that
um but i think it's going to be an
interesting new project totally dif you
know my entire youtube career has been
in news and politics so i know like the
norms on news and politics i know
monetization on news and politics i know
what are the controversies
this is just a completely new area
and uh why not dedicate a day of the
week on the show to financial stuff
it'll get lost
and i think that
it's such different content it's
evergreen in a way that news and
politics is not that i don't want to mix
it in it's really its own thing
dumps of cash hmm interesting um people
asking if i'm going to have any legal
trouble doing advising i'm not advising
anyone on anything
i'm not advising anyone it'll be stuff
like oh
when does it make sense to pay off a
mortgage how do you calculate whether
you should lease a car or buy a car
um
does it make sense to try to time the
stock market it's not going to be
specific advice for anybody in
particular
all right so everybody relax we're going
to be fully in compliance in every sense
of the word david can you also do travel
tips like where to get a bagel in buenos
aires in the style of bill o'reilly you
know i'm not going to be doing that
right now austin thank you
elements of finance that's an
idea uh we'll consider all of these
we'll consider consider all of these i
want to say thank you to gordon hall for
gifting a subscription on my website and
thanks to taylor pergram for signing up
as well putting us at 49.
also want to say thanks to your billion
sedated
skittle stew
yo samurai
staley explores for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 54 and if
you're just joining us you have missed
nothing yet you've missed nothing yet
this the uh hearing starts at the top of
the hour
fine answers
fine answers as opposed to fine answers
interesting that's interesting
roach red
says as a former borum hill resident
while smith street bagels people are
great i suggest you give court street
bagels a shot for the food oh i'm a
court street guy
don't get me wrong
i don't know who uh
wait no i'm a smith street guy now i get
the two confused yeah no both are good
quartz street bagels and smith street
bagels are both good i i that's legit
that's legit roach red
um there's also the smoked salmon joint
which i'm not even going to mention
because i don't want people showing up
and just you know
i want i don't want huge lines i don't
want to jeopardize my own bagels that
would be crazy
thanks to milo wild for gifting five
subscriptions on twitch i appreciate
that um skittle stew just gifted another
50 subscriptions if you can believe it
that is absolutely
unbelievable an anonymous gifter gifted
five more no lad signing up
lime king and cod fisher
we're already at 117 guys
and thanks to snappy dragon this it's
actually getting nuts here today
it's beyond belief quite frankly
please call in to bill's show and debate
the state of bagels with him yeah i
would debate bill o'reilly on bagels
david sir i have an unexpected vacation
because i tested positive for covet i'm
double back vaxxed and boosted symptoms
minimal but i get to spend my night
watching this with you and everyone else
well i'm glad to have you here
i'm glad to have you here but i hope uh
i hope it's mild did you think of
running for office before no i've only
thought of running for office in the
future
um i no i really haven't i really
haven't all right let's continue with a
few other things okay because there are
so many different things to get to next
oh this is very very interesting
there's a news anchor on fox 61 who
seems to have no idea about the
existence of alexandria ocasio-cortez
check out this pronunciation this is a
massive dump 39 more than a dozen
congressional lawmakers were arrested
during a pro-abortion protest in front
of the supreme court yesterday among
those arrested new york congresswoman
alexandria
cortez yeah alexandria asiago cortez you
guys know that it's one of the best
cheeses around
very very del it's it's delightful
minnesota oh thank you
thank you tim minnesota congresswoman
eliano marr
was at ilyan or
several others the u.s capitol police
says 17 members of congress were taken
into custody for blocking traffic during
that demonstration
there you go let's listen to it once
more in front of the supreme court
yesterday among those arrested new york
congresswoman alexandria
osceoso cortez asiatso
pretty good
uh okay
so that's pretty interesting
let me say thank you to bobby ganoush
and snappy dragon for the twitch prime
subscriptions
and skittle stew dumping in another 50
subscriptions skittle stew
skittle stew has jumped into third place
all time for gifted twitch subs at 287
that's huge skittle stew thank you
very much appreciate that
um
okay other super chats damn miss the
mangoes just got off work love your
channel sir and your audience thank you
glad to have you here
uh cyber hacks great to see you
let's look at a couple other things here
this is kind of interesting the last
real liberal
glenn greenwald is going to be hosting
a live q a with
delusional and dangerous conspiracy
theorist alex jones
the only real liberals left guys are
tulsi gabbard
glenn greenwald and kim iverson
everybody else has jumped the shark
those are the real liberals
can't trust anybody else
okay
and yeah that's not for real that's a
joke
okay
next
oh speaking of uh speaking of kim
iverson trans activist esperanza
debated kim iverson
and
from what i understand it got pretty
crazy let's let's listen to a little bit
of it
women which they consider to be a class
um but you know just to be fair um kim i
think that one of the reasons why people
were calling you transphobic was because
one um you were attempting to argue for
the right to dead name transgender
people and two because you know you
speak on trans issues without having
necessarily even done basic
investigation um for example you know
arguing on twitter that um if a trans
per if a trans child doesn't ask for
puberty blockers that they're in a phase
um you know you didn't even know what
the acronym turf standed for and i think
that this is a part of a broader problem
with political commentary
in our country where there's no rigorous
investigation demanded as a prerequisite
to speak on issues and you have people
who are influencing public opinion who
don't even do basic research and i think
that that's a big problem
do you not think that there is an
increase in children younger teens
uh saying that they feel that they that
they're non-binary or that they feel
like they're the other gender i mean are
we seeing an increase in that
it and i guess then the question is is
that an increase because
of
of because it's a phase i mean i do i do
think that teenagers go through phases i
think that that's that's
i don't think i need to do why is kim
iverson so annoying like i just don't
care what you know i was like okay you
have terrible ideas about everything why
would anyone listen to you too much more
research on that to know that i think
most of us know that teenagers go
through phases what they then choose to
make their face
tends to be the fad of the era that is
that is how it is it doesn't diminish or
or you know it doesn't diminish the fact
that
these that whatever it is they're
latching on to exists and exists and is
a reality for certain groups of people
it just means that they
you know they're saying okay well that's
me now that's what i feel like i'm i'm
maybe and it could be any number of
things or any number of things that they
want to try out or any number of things
they want to do
so i i don't know
you know certainly i guess there would
be a question on is there an increase in
who's the host is the host in the upper
right is that is this the show this is
happening on bad faith kids coming out
and saying to their parents
you know i'm feeling a certain way is
there an increase of that because
they're more the society's more open
or is it and so they feel like they can
say things and i know that's been an
argument in the past for for example
about whether or not somebody feel you
know if they feel like they can come out
as gay or what is she talking about
something um or is that
or it or do you think that there's all
is seeming pretty bad faith i have to
say influence in society
and i think that is where you know what
i was coming from but to be labeled a
transphobe for expressing an opinion i
think is my ultimate and you know
overall problem
with and what i'm saying about the
activist group that constantly then goes
after people and says i'm pretty you
know that thing about how like if you
put a thousand monkeys in front of a
thousand typewriters eventually they'd
write macbeth
i think that that was how this
diatribe was generated it's random
monkeys typing words well now you're a
bigot because you asked a question or
because you have a thought i can
disagree with somebody i can and this is
what kind of the overall
problem i had with the um
with that segment going viral and people
then calling me names
is that we've reached a point in society
and this it's not new this is how long
has she been talking happening it's new
it's newer on the left it used to happen
a lot on the right but we've reached a
point where
you know if you question anything if you
just say look i don't agree
suddenly i'm a bigot but why can't i not
be a bigot and not agree with you
well i just i want to say too that you
know we could discuss the reasons why
for example younger adults are more
likely than older adults to identify as
transgender we could discuss those
trends but there needs to be a level of
rigor a level of scientific rigor that
is demanded of people
who have platforms who are influencing
public opinion otherwise these
conversations are just going to
be like a sheet that you hold up in the
wind and whichever the way the wind
blows your opinion is going to be
influenced and that could be extremely
harmful especially when you're talking
about a group such as transgender people
who are disproportionately discriminated
against harassed uh and you know killed
in our society um and again that's why i
think you know let's not be juvenile
here i get hate all the time on twitter
um but we can't pretend like uh that's
the reason that you know
violence against transgender people
exists i mean the state has repressed
transgender people and gender variant
gender diverse people since before the
trans movement ever arose so
historically speaking that just simply
cannot be the reason for anti-trans
violence right because it existed before
the activist movement did well let me
let me see if i can tease out a couple
of things here
all right well
uh
yeah so that's that i mean i guess i
don't know how much more there is really
to say about it
but there's uh kim iverson with
opinions about trans i mean there she's
entitled to her opinions and
i don't even know what else to say about
it listen thank you to skittle stew for
dumping in another hundred
hundred twitch subscriptions thanks to
chunky strudel malwreck lambert 417
for the twitch prime subscriptions and i
do have to thank people signing up on
our website stephen bond has just gifted
a membership
jacob page has just gifted one gordon
hall sends a gift jason sickmeyer sends
a gift and jacob page with another one
that's 279.
let's go for 300.
uh okay let's look at a few other
oh i don't have any other super chats it
looks like okay
no problem
um
yeah
all right let's
let's continue and see what else we've
got
here is a cristo fascist indoctrination
ceremony
this is extremely disturbing
extremely disturbing
all right go ahead all right dutch leave
us so we'll read it together okay
as a patriot of faith i attest my
allegiance first and foremost to the
kingdom of god and the great commission
secondly i agreed to be a watchman over
our nation concerning its people and
their rights for life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
whereas we the church are god's
governing body on the earth
whereas we have been given legal power
from heaven and now exercise our
authority
whereas we are god's ambassadors and
spokespeople over the earth
whereas through the power of god we are
the world influencers this is really not
a cult nobody needs to worry that this
is a cult
[Applause]
don't tell me this is four minutes long
oh my god it is look at that
it's really four minutes
oh oh no it glitched out
oh hold on a second
let's see what the deal is
oh it is
oh my god they're it's they're on point
number 12. look at this
[Applause]
all right i i gotta get away from it
it's it's completely bonkers um tim
poole called the ohio child rape story a
hoax
apparently even after it was confirmed
to be true like initially a bunch of
right wingers called it a hoax
but then i guess tim poole was still
calling it a hoax after we knew it
wasn't
imagine what would happen
a little girl went to a clinic
and
they denied her
and then the left went look at what's
happening
that would have been a powerful powerful
smack in the face
of what was happening with these bills
with these heartbeat bills okay there's
a reason why they didn't try
because the greater possibility was
medical exemption
there's no rape kit
there were no criminal charges not until
now
why didn't anyone knowing this girl
report this this is why i say ladies and
gentlemen i do believe it is a hoax now
as to my previous statements i want to
make sure i clarify
i don't i don't like
the the vague natures of this
there is a possibility that a little
girl a family might say
we go to the hospital and we seek an
abortion
and they don't give it to you
well that's it it's over
you're done you will carry it and they
will not let you leave and then what do
we do
that's possible
and that's the kind of thing we need to
be careful about
but
i will say
the opportunity for the left here was
the pr move which says to me
i think it's a hoax
i think it is
a hoax in the sense oh and i love the
left is going to freak out so you really
happen i know it really happened i mean
we've got it here oh we've got the guy
being criminally charged lock him up
throw away the key put him out of the
country whatever okay illegal immigrant
who did this
this poor child
but i think the left is as manufacturing
and manipulating the circumstances to
create one political story it literally
is what it was described as what is he
even talking about
he's like the story is completely true
but the left has manipulated it into a
hoax well which aspect because
they probably would have gotten the
services under the medical exemption and
if they didn't it would have resulted in
the the ag coming out and saying this is
wrong and we're going to make sure she
gets the medical services she needs oh
the hoax is that if they had like
filed legal action they could have
gotten the abortion in ohio i guess
that's the hoax or something like that
very very strange strange not not like a
hoax i've ever seen that's uh that's for
damn sure super chat's coming in chitty
says david sir what are your favorite
seinfeld episodes mine are opposite
bizarro cherry jerry
nap and gum
good luck to argentina in the world cup
i don't really know what my favorite
seinfeld episodes are the marble rye is
really really good
um but i mean every episode there's very
few like throwaway
seinfeld episodes marine biologist is a
very good one yep for sure that's a good
one
senior david saludo santa ana california
can't wait for the new channel best of
luck thank you very much
as a veteran who swore to protect and
defend the constitution that was
absolutely disgusting which of the four
things haley because i played a lot of
disgusting things
i uh have to thank
skittlestu
who just gifted
another 50 subscriptions putting us at
329.
guys let's go for 400.
i want to say thanks to blueberry babe
newfisaurus rex
for two have one and his dudeness and
nikki putting us at 3 34
and also thanks to people signing up on
my website aaron brooks is a new member
and christine
dearell i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly and also a big thank you to
amber fritz for gifting a subscription
on the website if you want a free
subscription go to davidpakman.com
free subscriptions we're down to only
about 180 people waiting for free
website memberships that's actually very
low it's been as high as 600 but we've
been able to kind of clear the pipes
uh thanks to people's gifts so if you
want a free membership on my website go
to davidpakman.com
free membership okay very very simple
um
okay we have an idea for your money
talks youtube channel if someone hasn't
thought of this one yet pack on stacks
or something to that effect
okay
it's an idea
being a tesla electric vehicle driver in
minnesota who drives all over i found
janine's electric vehicle comments
amusing i prefer caribou coffee too
all right thank you joe
it was that gross cult chant okay that
was the extra gross thing thank you
haley i very much appreciate that all
right let's get to a couple of other
things oh i wanted to play a couple of
voicemails
uh because voicemails are coming in two
one nine two david p is the number
um a lot of people calling in about
jessie lee peterson
hey david it's science in brookfield
after i viewed that clip of jessie lee
peterson now causing that accident while
he's being harassed by that uh reporter
you know he's a despicable human being
but when you step back and look at what
what he's what a cultured soul he must
be he's born with that defense you could
tell he's got a hair looked in a closed
palette so i don't know maybe and then
he's gay and he passes games he's black
he can't stand black the self-loathing
of this man must be amazing yeah and to
think of you know and he's a sense of
repentance so his wife is his son
i would not be surprised if he commits
suicide okay because his life is so
f-stop well i hope that that doesn't
happen yeah if people don't know jessie
lee peterson
uh
well check this out this is this is what
happened
these are approaching a crosswalk
sometimes traffic gets going pretty fast
here and he looks like he's just going
to step right into it car slams on its
brakes car behind it slams into that car
you're running from your from your uh
what you've been doing for 31 years
oh my god and jesse lee doesn't even
react to the car wreck he causes
jesse's so upset that he uh tried to
cross the street before he should have
and caused these cars to stop and bash
and
that's pretty serious damage
so
that's because
what a situation right now it's insane
everything about it is completely insane
oh my god now i like you know just
to say he caused the accident i know
that all of our insurance people are
saying when you rear-end someone it's
your fault like they were following too
closely or going too quickly or whatever
but oh my god what an insane and the
casual nature when when the when the
crash happens
jesse doesn't even react
you're running from your from your uh
what you've been doing for 31
oh my years complete non-reaction from
jesse lee doesn't even react to the car
wreck he causes
jesse's so upset that he uh tried to
cross the street before he should have
and caused these cars to stop and bash
and
that's pretty serious damage
all right let's get away from it it's
completely nuts and we shouldn't be
laughing at a car accident i mean the
entire situation is crazy you know and
it's like the accident itself isn't
funny and obviously i hope nobody got
hurt obviously obviously obviously but
it's like truth is stranger than fiction
folks skittle stew just gifted another
50 subscriptions putting us at 387
also want to say thanks to lantern jim
jen here and mushroom wand
uh putting us at three nine zero we are
about 15 minutes away from the start of
this committee hearing and it's going to
be absolutely crazy absolutely crazy i'm
so glad that you're here
let me know in the chat do you think
they will show the excerpts of trump
struggling to record his message to the
rioters on the day after the riots let
me know if you think that will be part
of today it was teased
and i certainly hope that it will be
let's listen to a couple of other
voicemails voicemail number 219 to david
p
our friend juan has called in
hey david it's juan again
the reason why
the religious right
dislike hate or have
ill will against women
i think is a subconscious one
okay i'll give you two reasons please
number one
herodias
okay
king herod's
most recent wife
killed john the baptist out of hateful
grudge you know i'm gonna get away from
it
because this is a line of thought i'm
not that interested like i don't i don't
care what that it just i mean
i just don't think it's for this channel
let's try a different one from juan
hey david it's juan here i have a
question
do progressives dislike mainstream media
because in reality
they're not getting the attention that
they should be getting
and instead mainstream media is getting
in
is it because
of the lack of accuracy from mainstream
media is it both
i'd like to hear your thoughts oh man
low energy quan today no it's not about
dislike it's just like we annette we
analyze and recognize the shortcomings
uh of corporate media doesn't the
pedestrian have right-of-way there yeah
i mean it is a crosswalk didn't that's
true i mean i don't know if you just
literally run out of a store and run
across the crosswalk and cars can't slow
down i don't know i mean it sounds like
a complicated situation
looking forward to tonight's meltdown on
truth central oh trump is going to lose
it if they show clips of him struggling
to record the the rioter love letter
um oh mr pottinger see this uh
name tag here pottinger is the former
deputy national security advisor to
trump so he's testifying that's gonna be
nuts
david reacting to a video of himself
reacting to a video of jesse lee
peterson causing an accident yeah it's
very meta
very very meta content today for sure
welcome to black white rook thanks for
the twitch prime subscription putting us
at 391.
um do you think mark meadows will
testify tonight and if he was the one
that trump attempted to call
no and yes
here are a number of the different
officers including michael fanon uh
capitol police officers they have been
attending these events this is a major
major deal
this is going to be a major event
tonight i i hope people are ready for a
major major event because uh this is
going to be serious stuff very very
serious stuff david just thought of a
youtube name idea financing the future
with pacman and friends yeah that's
maybe a little too verbose but
why did jesse lee peterson cross the
road to get to the other side get it
no anyone
indeed
indeed
couple other voicemails here's one fresh
off the presses
david sir it's tommy in wisconsin
i have
under good authority
that the
special witness tonight in the hearings
will be all the machines from the class
action lawsuit filed by pillow love the
show thanks we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines we are
actually going to see interrogation
video
of my milk wand being uh
brutally
placed under um truth theorem
and forced
to confess
that's going to be today it's going to
be really really crazy no doubt about it
let's see what else we've got from the
standpoint of voicemails
so ben was saying that the royals are
like inbred or something like that but i
think that's just like the spanish line
um that was ruining england for a while
were inbred like really really really
really really really ugly [ __ ]
but so growing up uh one of
my best friend's girlfriends
uh she
was spanish and or spanish or whatever
and she said that like her and her
cousin or something got it on so they're
like still doing all right guys we're
gonna get away from that that's a bit
too racy for this channel
um we're this is like a serious event
tonight and i we've got a lot of new
people watching so i just can't i can't
have that going on okay
new channel data mail that's an
interesting one
that could work
that could work
um moments away folks moments moments
away i say you call the channel many
many monies with david pakman that's
larry's idea that's it's an idea
thanks tracy bay photo speaking of
machines sir why was your espresso
machine at the capitol on january 6th
should see where my lawnmower was
is the finance channel another shill to
make money like the bonus show
absolutely hold on where do i have that
globalist internationalist trotskyite
socialists unlike obama trudeau mccrone
and the rest of these zio beasts
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad exactly everybody
knows what's going on okay
hey david uh just one quick question um
when it comes to the prosecution of
donald trump um
what i don't understand is
why the attorney general or whoever
why would they
why they would hesitate
when the president of the united states
i guess and ties with the american
people
um is not above the law
um just want your thoughts on that david
yeah we've talked about that extensively
i mean i think the prosecutors don't
necessarily want to be the first to be
like i'm charging a president
uh because it's unclear
what the repercussions would be i think
if trump was charged in one place he
would be potentially charged in multiple
places and the
um floodgates would open for lack of a
better term but i think there is
understandable although i believe
overblown
hesitation on that
from um
many prosecutors district attorneys etc
industry says crossers have a duty to
cross safely drivers are rarely charged
when they hit or even kill pedestrians
you know there's a very interesting
article i read about how
it's increasingly a way that hit men
hitmen
are um
carrying out murders which is you just
set it up to look like a car accident
because indeed they are rarely charged
it's it's a very it's horrifying but i
did i did read very interesting article
about that
show name oh you want to make money with
david pakman that's an idea for the show
for the channel it's not a bad idea
uh okay
let's listen to one more
david sir i hear you're self-shilling
for your bonus show
uh is that even legal thanks bye yeah i
can't worry i can't even deal with that
tonight
just can't do it
can't do it can't do it tonight okay if
you're just joining us we are moments
away
from the final as far as i know
january 6th committee hearing
we are going to hear from the former
trump deputy
national security adviser
uh matthew pottinger
we are reportedly going to see
excerpts of donald trump struggling with
what to say in a message to the writers
in the aftermath of the riots seems
super interesting and we may see or hear
testimony from donald trump's former
lawyer patsy bologna
correctly known as pat sipoloni all of
that and potentially more
on during today's hearings and it's
going to be stunning
ryan says adjuster here since there's
video i think both insurance comps
companies will try to deny liability
because he clearly was the proximate
cause here all right ryan weighing in
pacman's piggy bank and the worst part
about jesse is he's sexually assaulting
men from his men's program conversion
therapy and tells him it's a second
baptism it's all kinds of messed up it
really is
it really is
all right guys i'm gonna only mention
this once
i need you to do me a favor it's not
illegal it's not finding me 11 000 votes
uh everything we do is primarily
supported by our audience i would love
it if you went to my website
joinpakman.com
and grabbed a membership the memberships
come with great strength and great
benefits including the bonus show
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show and priority access
during tuesday's town hall you'll get a
dedicated member only way to get in
touch with me today's coupon code is
indict as you can see above my head
it shouldn't need explanation
the meaning of that coupon code should
be clear given the subject matter and
the coupon code offers such a discount
that i don't even want to go into detail
with percentages now if you don't like
the coupon code indict and you prefer
something different
you can use the coupon code obama as
well it's actually an even bigger
discount
okay i will do
my holy best
to thank every single person
which which one of these will be on i
think this one right every single person
we need higher quality than this
who uh gets a membership on the website
today
that's my promise to you
as we are now visibly struggling with
some of these streams going in and out
there we go we're back okay good uh
indict obama
it's the one of your choice skittle stew
has just gifted 51 more subscriptions
putting us at 442
and pushing skittle stew
within
16 gifted subscriptions of being the
all-time top gifter on twitch
on twitch the top gifter of all time i'm
inconsolable is currently at 5 55.
skittle stew has pulled within 16 at 539
gifted subscriptions
it is a shot across the bow
for lack of a better term
thanks also to guitar goddess
for
the gifted subscription very much
appreciate that
other super chats coming in david i love
the video of the guy in the church that
says he's not gay anymore and he doesn't
like men no more you were so funny when
you were kind of dancing so funny where
is it oh that is one of my favorite
videos
it's sad in a way
but it's also so funny
uh let me see if i can find it i'm not
gay no more
is the name of it
uh
yeah here it is
so this is visually funny but also sad
and the guy is gay and he later told
jimmy kimmel i'm still gay
you need god to do
he just told you it's done i believe
this is one of the best videos on the
internet right now what did you come
here for what did you come down here for
tell me to get delivered more
get delivered
do you believe that the lord tonight has
set you free yes sir
turn around and tell those people
i'm not gay no more i am deliberate
[Music]
[Music]
i would not carry a purse i would not
put on makeup
i will
i will
love
a woman and we will
now listen here it is y'all praise god
with him hold on wait a minute hold just
one minute
now either you gonna believe this stuff
or you ought to stop preaching it yeah
i would stop preaching it if you can't
praise god with him you're an unbeliever
now somebody believed god with him
[Music]
i'm not gay no more i am delivered so
anyway you get the picture that's the
video it is it is a stunning video
uh absolutely one of my favorites really
hard to beat it very very hard to beat
it
uh okay let's see what else we've got
here david sir i need 11 780 french
fries for my ketchup give me a break
helping a new dad with diapers thank you
uh thanks for all you do david p much
respect thank you i very much appreciate
that
um
okay
let me thank people dumping in
memberships on my website this is crazy
john mcnamara is a new member hector
simpson has signed up
spence peacock is a new member jay
sherman new member christopher kaufman
has signed up kenneth mello is a new
member ty sullivan has signed up
clevira wang is a new member
mickey mfay has signed up
uh oh boy i'm having trouble keeping up
tracy tolman new member peter harm's new
member that's 10 putting us at 453. guys
i think this might be a record
i think we're hitting a record and then
the gifts are dumping in oh wait no hold
on there's more christopher simpson new
member ryan irwin new member
uh
no this one's not it hold on wesley
fritz is a new member
that's 456.
i don't think we've ever had 500
witnesses entering
witnesses entering
we are starting very soon
then he said sir david is your
standpoint on stand pointing still the
best we've ever seen also sir thank you
for all you dodo yes i said well
detonation is on fire today
let's listen
little audio so far
thanks to oceanova for the twitch prime
subscription
um
voicemails continue to come in
hi david this is mike from hamilton
ontario canada you got to call your new
show david n
like dividends
but david ends maybe a little gayer but
you know you'd it would be perfect
what
it's bizarre
david steve from
canada calling
it a sort of an idea for your financial
business or your financial video um
streaming site yeah maybe call it a
financial pack
anyway great skill my friend keep up the
good work
financial pack
all right
uh thanks to gene cotton for signing up
on my website
holly hutcheson
genevieve campbell
and ladonna sullivan very much
appreciate that puts us at 461. but
we've never had 500 but we will see we
will uh we will continue tallying
other super chats coming in
uh no text thanks eamon appreciate that
also thank you to everyone gifting
subscriptions i can't even name
everybody but it's one two three
four
five six seven
eight
10 11 12.
12 gifted subscriptions puts us at 473
and then a few more
this program was made possible by
contributions to your pbs station from
viewers like you
thank you
it's happening
[Music]
good evening i'm judy woodruff and
welcome to this pbs newshour special all
right let's see if we can get video in
the room here we go i prefer the video
in the room and of course only the best
for my audience we want it in uh highest
the highest definition possible
uh folks if you have any thoughts about
what we're going to see of course you
can always send a super chat
hey david this is callie from alabama i
just wanted to say that i love your show
and keep up the great work my friend
thank you appreciate that very much
uh skittle stew has just gifted another
50
community subscriptions on twitch
putting us
at 5 28. folks let's go for 550 that
pushes skittle stew into the number one
gifter of all time
on the youtube channel
thanks to tr napsta
may rican has just gifted 10 that puts
us at 5 39 this is a record the russia
investigation uh ukraine impeachment
even the impeachment at the beginning of
last year here we go
in those instances there were a handful
of witnesses who stepped forward as
whistleblowers uh those people didn't
necessarily get what they might have
ultimately wanted out of that process
and what that does is it sends a signal
to future see if the pbs feed yeah i
prefer the pbs feed let's stick with
this one chair congresswoman liz cheney
these are live pictures from the hearing
room at the couch here we go
good evening
earlier this week i received a positive
coverage diagnosis oh boy per cdc
guidelines i've received the initial two
shots and all of the boosters thus far
i've been blessed to experience very
minimal symptoms
because i'm still quarantined i cannot
participate
in person with my colleagues
i've asked our vice chair ms cheney to
preside over this evening's hearing
including maintaining order in the room
and swearing in our witnesses
over the last month and a half
the select committee has told the story
of a president who did everything in his
power to overturn an election
he lied
he bullied he betrayed his oath
he tried to destroy democratic
institutions
he summoned a mob to washington
after war on january 6
when he knew that the assembled mob was
heavily armed and angry he commanded the
mob to go to the capitol and he
emphatically commanded the heavily armed
mall
to fight like hell
true for the weeks between
november election and january 6
donald trump was a force to be reckoned
with
he struck off the factuality and
legality correct sober advice
of his knowledgeable and sensible
advisors
instead he recklessly blazed a path
of lawlessness and corruption
the cost to which democracy
be damned
and then he stopped
for 187 minutes on january 6
this man of unbridled destructive energy
could not be moved not by his age not by
his allies not by the violent chance of
riotous or the desperate pleas of those
facing down the
and more tellingly
donald trump ignored and disregarded the
desperate pleas of his own family
including ivanka and don jr
even though he was the only person in
the world
who could call off the mob
he's sent to the capitol
he could not be moved to rise from his
dining room table
and walk the few steps down the white
house hallway
into the press briefing room where
cameras were anxiously
and desperately waiting to carry his
message to the armed and violent mob
savagely beating and killing law
enforcement officers
revenging the capital and hunting down
the vice president and various members
of congress
he could not be moved
this evening
my colleagues mr kingsinger of illinois
and miss luria of virginia will take you
inside the white house during those 187
minutes wow
we also remind you of what was happening
at the capitol minute by minute
as the found violent tragic part of
donald trump's scheme to cling to power
unravel while he ignored his advisors
stood by and watched it unfold on
television
let me offer a found thought about the
select committee's work so far
as we've made clear throughout these
hearings
our investigation goes forward
we continue to receive new information
every day we continue to hear from
witnesses
we will reconvene in september to
continue laying out our findings to the
american people
but as that work goes forward
a number of facts are clear
there can be no doubt that there was a
coordinated multi-step effort to
overturn an election overseen and
directed
by donald trump
there could be no doubt that he
commanded a mob
a mob he knew was heavily armed violent
and angry to march on the capitol to try
to stop the peaceful transfer of power
and he made targets
out of his own vice president
and the lawmakers gathered to do the
people's work
these facts have gone undisputed
and so there needs to be accountability
accountability
under the law
accountability to the american people
accountability at every level from the
local precincts in many states
where donald trump and his allies
attacked election workers for just doing
their jobs
all the way up to the oval office where
donald trump embraced a legal advice
of insurrectionists that a federal judge
has already said was a coup
in search of a legal theory
our democracy withstood the attack on
january 6th
if there is no accountability for
january 6
for every part of this scheme
i feel that we will not overcome
the ongoing threat to our democracy for
sure there must be stiff consequences
for those responsible
now i'll turn things over to our vice
chair
to start telling this story here we go
thank you mr chairman
without objection the presiding officer
is authorized to declare the committee
in recess at any point
pursuant to house deposition authority
regulation 10 i announced that the
committee has approved the release of
the deposition material presented during
today's hearing
and let me begin tonight by wishing
chairman thompson a rapid recovery from
covid
he has expertly led us through eight
hearings so far and he has brought us to
the point we are today
in our initial hearing the chairman and
i described what ultimately became
donald trump's seven-part plan to
overturn the 2020 presidential election
a plan stretching from before election
day through january 6th
at the close of today's hearing our
ninth we will have addressed each
element of that plan
but in the course of these hearings we
have received new evidence and new
witnesses have bravely stepped forward
efforts to litigate and overcome
immunity and executive privilege claims
have been successful and those continue
doors have opened new subpoenas have
been issued and the dam has begun to
break
and now even as we conduct our ninth
hearing we have considerably more to do
we have far more evidence to share with
the american people and more to gather
so our committee will spend august
pursuing emerging information on
multiple fronts before convening further
hearings this september wow
today we know far more about the
president's plans and actions to
overturn the election than almost all
members of congress did when president
trump was impeached on january 13 2021
or when he was tried by the senate in
february of that year
57 of 100 senators voted to convict
president trump at that time
and more than 20 others said they were
voting against conviction because the
president's term had already expired
at the time the republican leader of the
united states senate said this about
donald trump
ahmad
was assaulting the capital in his name
these criminals were carrying his
banners
hanging his flags
and screaming their loyalty to him
it was obvious
but only president trump
could end this
he was the only one
leader mcconnell reached those
conclusions based on what he knew then
without any of the much more detailed
evidence you will see today
lawlessness and violence began at the
capitol on january 6 2021 before 1 pm
and continued until well after darkness
fell
what exactly was our commander in chief
doing during the hours of violence today
we addressed precisely that issue all
right everything you've heard in these
hearings thus far will help you
understand president trump's motives
during the violence
you already know donald trump's goal
to halt or delay congress's official
proceedings to count certified electoral
votes
you know that donald trump tried to
pressure his vice president to illegally
reject votes and delay the proceedings
you know he tried to convince state
officials and state legislators to flip
their electoral votes from biden to
trump
and you know donald trump tried to
corrupt our department of justice to aid
his scheme
but by january 6 none of that had worked
only one thing was succeeding on the
afternoon of january 6th
only one thing was achieving president
trump's goal
the angry armed mob president trump sent
to the capitol broke through security
invaded the capitol and forced the vote
counting to stop
that mob was violent and destructive and
many came armed
as you will hear
secret service agents protecting the
vice president were exceptionally
concerned about his safety and their own
republican leader kevin mccarthy was
scared
as were others in congress
even those who themselves helped to
provoke the violence
and as you will see today donald trump's
own white house counsel his own white
house staff members of his own family
all implored him to immediately
intervene to condemn the violence and
instruct his supporters to stand down
leave the capitol and disperse
for multiple hours he would not
donald trump would not get on the phone
and order the military or law
enforcement agencies to help
and for hours donald trump chose not to
answer the pleas from congress from his
own party and from all across our nation
to do what his oath required
he refused to defend our nation and our
constitution
he refused to do what every american
president must in the days after january
6 almost no one of any political party
would defend president trump's conduct
and no one should do so today
thank you and i now recognize the
gentlewoman from virginia
thank you madam vice chair
article two of our constitution requires
that the presidents swear a very
specific oath every four years
every president swears or affirms to
faithfully execute the office of
president of the united states
and to the best of their ability
preserve protect and defend the
constitution of the united states
the president also assumes the
constitutional duty to take care that
our nation's laws be faithfully executed
and is the commander-in-chief of our
military
our hearings have shown
the many ways in which president trump
tried to stop the peaceful transfer of
power in the days leading up to january
6th
with each step of his plan he betrayed
his oath of office
and was derelict in his duty
tonight we will further examine
president trump's actions on the day of
the attack on the capitol
early that afternoon
president trump instructed tens of
thousands of supporters ed and near the
ellipse rally trump says it was millions
whom he knew were armed with various
types of weapons to march to the capitol
after telling the crowd to march
multiple times he promised he would be
with them and finished his remarks at 1
10 pm like this
we're going to walk down and i'll be
there with you
we're going to walk down
we're going to walk down
anyone you want but i think right here
we're going to walk down to the capitol
so let's walk down pennsylvania avenue
by this time the vice president was in
the capital the joint session of
congress to certify joe biden's victory
was underway and the proud boys and
other rioters had stormed through the
first barriers and begun the attack
radio communications from law
enforcement informed secret service and
those in the white house situation room
of these developments in real time
at the direction of president trump
thousands more rioters march from the
ellipse to the capital
and they joined the attack
as you will see in great detail tonight
president trump was being advised by
nearly everyone to immediately instruct
his supporters to leave the capital
disperse and halt the violence
virtually everyone told president trump
to condemn the violence in clear and
unmistakable terms
and those on capitol hill
and across the nation begged president
trump to help
but the former president chose not to do
what all of those people begged he
refused to tell the mob to leave until 4
17
when he tweeted out a video statement
filmed in the rose garden
ending with this
we love you so go home
we love you you're very special
you've seen what happens you see the way
others are treated that are
so bad and so evil
i know how you feel
but go home and go home in peace
by that time two pipe bombs had been
found at locations near the capitol
including where the vice president-elect
was conducting a meeting
hours of hand-to-hand combat had
seriously injured scores of law
enforcement officers
the capital had been invaded the
electoral count had been halted as
members were evacuated
reiter's took the floor of the senate
they rifled through desks and broke into
offices and they nearly caught up to
vice president pence
guns were drawn on the house floor and a
rioter was shot attempting to infiltrate
the chamber
we know that a number of rioters
intended acts of physical violence
against specific elected officials
we know virtually all the rioters were
motivated by president trump's rhetoric
that the election had been stolen and
they felt they needed to take their
country back
this hearing is principally about what
happened inside of the white house that
afternoon
from the time when president trump ended
his speech until the moment when he
finally told the mob to go home
a span of 187 minutes more than three
hours
what you will learn is that president
trump sat in his dining room and watched
the attack on television while his
senior most staff closest advisors and
family members begged him to do what is
expected of any american president
i served proudly for 20 years as an
officer in the united states navy
veterans of our armed forces know
firsthand the leadership that's required
in a time of crisis
urgent and decisive action that puts
duty and country first
but on january 6
when lives and our democracy hung in the
balance
president trump refused to act because
of his selfish desire to stay in power
and i yield to the gentleman from
illinois mr kensinger thank you thank
you ms lauria
one week after the attack republican
leader kevin mccarthy acknowledged the
simple truth
president trump should have acted
immediately
to stop the violence
during our investigation general mark
milley the chairman of the joint chiefs
of staff also remarked on the
president's failure to act let's hear
what they had to say
the president bears responsibility for
wednesday's attack on congress by mob
rioters
he should have immediately denounced the
mob when he saw what was unfolding
these facts require immediate action by
president trump
yeah
he's a commander-in-chief you've got an
assault going on on the capital of the
united states of america
and there's nothing
no call nothing zero
like my colleague from virginia i'm a
veteran i served in the air force and i
serve currently in the air national
guard
i can tell you that general milley's
reaction to president trump's conduct is
100 percent correct
and so was leader mccarthy's
what explains president trump's behavior
why did he not take immediate action in
a time of crisis
because president trump's plan for
january 6 was to halt or delay
congress's official proceeding to count
the votes the mob attacked the capital
quick the the mob attacking the capital
quickly
caused the evacuation of both the house
and the senate
the count ground to an absolute halt and
was ultimately delayed for hours
the mob was accomplishing president
trump's purpose
so of course he didn't intervene
here's what will be clear by the end of
this hearing president trump did not
fail to act during the 187 minutes
between leaving the ellipse and telling
the mob to go home
he chose not to act
but there were hundreds that day who
honored their oaths and put their lives
on the line to protect the people inside
the capitol and to safeguard our
democracy
many of them are here tonight with us
and many more are watching from home
as you already know and we'll see again
tonight their service and sacrifice
shines a bright light
on president trump's dishonor
and dereliction of duty i yield to the
vice chair
thank you very much mr kinzinger i'd
like to begin by welcoming our witnesses
this evening
tonight we're joined by mr matthew
pottinger mr pottinger is a decorated
former marine intelligence officer who
served this nation on tours of duty in
afghanistan and iraq
he served in the trump white house from
the first day of the administration
through the early morning hours of
january 7th 2021.
the last role in which he served in the
white house was his deputy national
security adviser to the president of the
united states we're also joined by sarah
matthews
ms matthews started her career in
communications working on capitol hill
serving on the republican staffs of
several house committees
she then worked as deputy press
secretary for president trump's
re-election campaign before joining the
trump white house in june of 2020.
she served there as deputy press
secretary and special assistant to the
president
until the evening of january 6th 2021
i will now swear in our witnesses the
witnesses will please stand and raise
their right hands
do you swear or affirm under penalty of
perjury that the testimony you are about
to give is the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you god
thank you you may be seated and let the
record reflect that the witnesses
answered in the affirmative
thank you both again
for being here tonight
mr pottinger uh thank you for your
service to the nation uh as well as as
for joining us this evening
can you please briefly explain what your
responsibilities were as deputy national
security adviser to the president
thank you madam vice chair
when i started the white house i was a
senior director for asia on the national
security council staff so that was a job
that involved helping coordinate the
president's asia policy
i supported the president when he met or
interacted with asian leaders
later 2019 i was
promoted to the job of deputy national
security advisor
in that role
uh i was the chairman of the deputies
committee that's an nsc
uh uh meeting of all the deputy cabinet
secretaries we would settle uh
important matters of of uh national
policy related to to our national
security and we would also tee up
options for the president and uh for his
cabinet members
uh it was um
i i felt then as i do now that it was a
privilege to serve in the white house
i'm also very proud of president trump's
foreign policy accomplishments we were
able to
uh finally compete
with china we were
also able to broker uh peace agreements
between israel and and three arab states
i mean those are some examples of the
types of policies that i think made
our country safer
thank you miss patenter and were you in
the white house during the attack on the
capitol on january 6th uh for most of
the day i was
in the white house although when the the
president was speaking at the rally i
was actually off site at a scheduled
meeting with india's ambassador to the
united states
the
national security council staff was not
involved in organizing the security for
what was a domestic event the rally
but
i did return to the white house at
roughly 2 30 p.m
thank you and i know my colleagues will
have additional questions for you about
that afternoon
let me turn out to you miss matthews how
did you come to join president trump's
white house staff
thank you madam vice chair as you
outlined i am a lifelong republican and
um i joined the trump re-election
campaign in june of 2019 i was one of
the first communications staffers
actually on board for his re-election
campaign
and during that time
i traveled all around the country
and met kaylee mcinenneny who was also
working on his re-election campaign
i worked there for a year and i formed a
close relationship with miss mcineney
and
she moved over to the white house in
april of 2020 to start as white house
press secretary and she brought over a
group of campaign staff with her and so
i joined her over at the white house in
june of 2020 to start as her deputy
and were you ms matthews at work in the
white house on january 6th
yes i was working out of the west wing
that day
thank you
and now i'd like to recognize the
gentleman from virginia and the
gentleman from illinois
thank you madam vice chair
as you've seen in our prior hearings
president trump summoned the mob to dc
on january 6.
before he went on stage he knew some of
them were armed and prepared for combat
during his speech he implored them to
march to the capitol as he had always
planned to do
by the time he walked off the stage his
supporters had already breached the
outer perimeter of the capitol at the
foot of capitol hill
since our last hearings we've received
new testimony from a security
professional working in the white house
complex on january 6
with access to relevant information and
responsibility to report to national
security officials
this security official told us that the
white house was aware of multiple
reports of weapons in the crowd that
morning
we as a committee
are cognizant of the fear of retribution
expressed by certain national security
witnesses who have come forward to tell
the truth we've therefore taken steps to
protect this national security
individual's identity
listen to this clip from their testimony
from the people
about this idea of the president to walk
to the capitol
to be completely honest
you were all in the state of shock
because why
because it's just
one i think the actual physical
feasibility of doing it and then also we
all knew what i was impatient and what
that meant that this was no longer a
rally that this was going to move to
something else if he physically walked
to the camera
i don't know if you want to use the word
insurrection coup whatever we all knew
that this would move from a normal
democratic you know
public events into something else
what was what was driving that sentiment
considering
this this this part of it the actual
bridge of the capital hadn't happened
yet
why were we alarmed right
the president wanted to lead tens of
thousands of people to the capitol um
i think that was enough grounds for us
to be alarmed
even though he understood many of his
supporters were armed the president was
still adamant to go to the capitol when
he got off the stage at the ellipse
but his secret service detail was
equally determined to not let him go
that led to a heated argument with the
detail that delayed the departure of the
motorcade to the white house
we have evidence from multiple sources
regarding an angry exchange in the
presidential suv including testimony we
will disclose today from two witnesses
who confirmed that a confrontation
occurred the first witness is a former
white house employee with national
security responsibilities
after seeing the initial violence at the
capitol on tv
the individual went to see tony ornato
the deputy chief of staff in his office
mr ornato was there with bobby engel the
president's lead secret service agent
this employee told us that mr ornato
said that the president was quote irate
when mr ingle refused to drive him to
the capitol
mr ingle did not refute what mr ornato
said
the second witness is retired sergeant
mark robinson of the d.c police
department who was assigned to the
president's motorcade that day
he sat in the lead vehicle with a secret
service agent responsible for the
motorcade also called the ts agent
here's how sergeant robinson remembered
the exchange
was there any
description of what of what was
occurring in the car
no only that on the only description i
received was that the president was
upset
and that was adamant about going to the
capitol and there was a a heated
discussion about that
and when you say heated is that your
word or is that the word that was
described by the ts agent
were described by the tsa meaning that
the president was upset and he was
saying there was a heated argument or
discussion
about going to the capitol
about how many times would you say
you've been part of that motorcade with
president
probably over a hundred times
uh and then that a hundred times have
you ever
uh witnessed uh another discussion of a
argument or heated discussion with the
president
where the president was contradicting uh
where he was supposed to go or what the
secret service believe was safe
no
like other witnesses sergeant robinson
also testified that he was aware that
individuals in the crowd were armed
yes i believe he was on a special uh
events channel and
i was monitoring the traffic since so i
can hear
some of the units pointing out to
individuals that there were individuals
along constitution avenue that were
armed that were up in their trees and i
can hear the uh units responding to
those individuals
and so there's always a concern when
there's a potent
in the area
and like other witnesses sergeant
robinson told us that the president
still wanted to travel to the capitol
even after returning to the white house
so at the end of the speech what was the
plan supposed
to be
so at the end of the speech
we do know that while inside the limo
the president was still
adamant about going to
the capitol that's been relayed to me
by the ts agent and so
we did park the ellipse
and we responded back to the white house
however
we the the motorcade the potus motorcade
was placed on standby
and so we were told to stand by
uh on the west exact until they
confirmed whether or not the president
was going to go
to the capitol and so i
may have waited i would just estimate
maybe 45 to 45 minutes to an hour
um waiting for secret service to make
that decision
the motorcade waited at the white house
for more than 45 minutes before being
released
the committee is also aware that
accounts of the angry confrontation in
the presidential suv have circulated
widely among the secret service since
january 6.
recent disclosures have also caused the
committee to subpoena yet further
information from the secret service
which we've begun to receive and will
continue to assess
the committee is also aware that certain
secret service witnesses have now
retained new private council we
anticipate further testimony under oath
and other new information in the coming
weeks
after the secret service refused to take
president trump to the capitol he
returned to the white house
what you see on the screen is a photo of
him inside the oval office immediately
after he returned from the rally still
wearing his overcoat
a white house employee informed the
president
as soon as he returned to the oval about
the riot at the capitol
let me repeat that within 15 minutes of
leaving the stage president trump knew
that the capital was besieged and under
attack
at 1 25 president trump went to the
private dining room off the oval office
from 1 25 until 4 o'clock the president
stayed in his dining room
just to give you a sense of where the
dining room is situated in the west wing
let's take a look at this floor plan
the dining room is connected to the oval
office by a short hallway
witnesses told us that on january 6
president trump sat in his usual spot at
the head of the table facing a
television hanging on the wall
we know from the employee the tv was
tuned to fox news all afternoon
here you can see fox news on the tv
showing coverage of the joint session
that was airing that day at 1 25. show
the ketchup other witnesses confirmed
that president trump was in the dining
room with the tv on for more than two
and a half hours
there was no official record of what
president trump did while in the dining
room
on the screen is the presidential call
log from january 6.
as you can see there's no official
record
of president trump receiving or placing
a call between 1106
and 6 54 p.m suspicious as to what the
president was doing that afternoon the
presidential daily diary is also silent
it contains no information from the
period between 1 21 pm and 403 pm
there are also no photos of president
trump during this critical period
between 121 in the oval office and when
he went outside to the rose garden after
four o'clock
the chief white house photographer
wanted to take pictures because it was
in her words very important for his
archives and for history but she was
told quote
no photographs
despite the lack of photos or an
official record we've learned what
president trump was doing while he was
watching tv in the dining room but
before we get into that it's important
to understand
what he never did that day let's watch
so are you aware of any phone call by
the president of the united states to
the secretary of defense that day not
that i'm aware of note
are you aware of any phone call by the
president of the united states to the
attorney general of the united states
that day no
be aware of any phone call by the
president of the united states to the
secretary of homeland security that day
i i'm not aware of that now
did you ever get a vice president or
excuse me the president
asked for the national award did you
ever hear the president ask for law
enforcement response
no
so as somebody who worked in the
national security space and with the
national security council if there were
going to be troops present or called up
for
a rally in washington dc for example is
that something that you would have been
aware yeah i wouldn't do you know if you
asked anybody
to
reach out to any of those that we just
listed off national guard dod fbi
homeland security secret service mayor
bowser the capitol police about the
situation the capitol i am not
aware of any of those requests
no sir
we have confirmed in numerous interviews
with senior law enforcement and military
leaders
vice president pence's staff and d.c
government officials
none of them not one heard from
president trump that day
he did not call to issue orders he did
not call to offer assistance
this week we received a dedicional
testimony from yet another witness about
why the president didn't make any
efforts to quell the attack
the former white house employee with
national security responsibilities
told us about a conversation with senior
adviser eric hershman and pat sipoloni
the top white house lawyer
this conversation was about a pending
call from the pentagon seeking to
coordinate on the response to the attack
mr hirschman turned to mr sipoloni and
said
the president didn't want to do anything
and so mr bologna had to take the call
himself
so if president trump wasn't calling law
enforcement or military leaders what did
president trump spend his time doing
that afternoon while he first settled
into the dining room cheering the
rioters he was calling senators to
encourage them to delay or object to the
certification
here's kaylee mcaney his press secretary
to explain
all right then it says back there and he
wants lists of senators and then he's
calling them one by one do you know
which ones he called
to the best of my recollection no um
as i say in my notes he wanted a list of
the senators and you know i left him
at that point
because the presidential call log is
empty we do not yet know precisely which
senators president trump was calling
but we do know from rudy giuliani's
phone records that president trump also
called him at 139
after he had been told that the riot was
underway at the capitol
mr giuliani was president trump's lead
election attorney
according to the phone records the
president's call with him lasted
approximately four minutes
recall that fox news was on in the
dining room let's take a look at what
was airing as this call was ending
the president as we all saw fired this
crowd up they've all tens of thousands
maybe a hundred thousand or more have
gone down to the capitol or elsewhere in
the city and they're very upset now i
jumped down as soon as we heard the news
that brett gave you about mike pence i
started talking to these people i said
what do you think one woman an air force
veteran from missouri said she was quote
disgusted to hear that news and that it
was his duty to do something and i told
her i said there's nothing in the
constitution unilaterally that vice
president pence could do she said that
doesn't matter he should have fought for
trump
at 1 49 here's what was happening at the
capitol with president trump's fired up
supporters
[Applause]
but this is now effectively a riot
13 49 hours declaring a riot
[Applause]
what did president trump do at 149 as
the d.c police at the same time were
declaring a riot at the capitol
as you can see on the screen
he tweeted out a link to the recording
of his ellipse speech
this was the same speech in which he
knowingly sent an armed mob to the
capitol
but president trump made no comment
about the lawlessness and the violence
i yield to the gentleman from illinois
the next action president trump took
was to tweet
at 2 24 p.m
what happened during the 35 minutes
between his last tweet at 149 and 224
his staff repeatedly
came into the room to see him and plead
that he make a strong public statement
condemning the violence and instructing
the mob
to leave the capitol
he did not relent until after four
o'clock
when he went out to go to the rose
garden to film his now infamous go home
message
pat cipoloni was a top white house
lawyer
here's what he told us about his
reaction to seeing the violence and his
advice throughout the afternoon
when did you first realize that there
was actually
something
i i
first realized that it may have been on
television or it may have been
tony or may have been building but i i
found out that people were
you know they weren't in the capitol yet
but they were you know and then i
started watching it and you know
then i was aware
what specifically did you think you
would have done
i think i was pretty clear there need to
be an immediate
and forceful
response statement public statement that
people need to leave the capital now
my question is exactly that that it
sounds like you from the very onset of
violence the capital
right around two o'clock
we're pushing for a strong statement
that people should leave the capital is
that right
i was another soldier as well pat you
said that you expressed your opinion
forcefully could you
tell us exactly how you did that
yeah i can't i'm i'm going to have you
know i have to
on the privilege issue i can't talk
about conversations with the president
but i can generically say that i said
you know
people need to be told there needs to be
a public announcement
fast
that they need to leave the capitol
and pat could you let us know
approximately when you said that
approximately when almost immediately
after i found out people were getting
into the capital or
approaching the capital in a way that
was
was violent
do you remember any discussion with mark
meadows with respect to
his his view that the president didn't
want to do anything
was somehow resistant to
wanting to say something along the lines
that he suggests
just to be clear
many people suggested it um
not just me many people felt the same
way
um
i'm sure i had conversations with mark
about this during the course of the day
and expressed my
my opinion very forcefully that
this needs to be done so your advice was
tell people in the capital and that took
over two hours when there were
subsequent statements made tweets put
forth that in your view were
insufficient did you continue simple
money throughout the period of time
up until 417 continue you and others to
push for a stronger state yes
were you joined in that effort by ivanka
trump yes eric hershey yes i'm mark
meadow yes
white house counsel's office wanted
there to be a strong statement out to
condemn the rioters i'm confident in
that i'm confident that ivanka trump
wanted there to be a strong statement to
condemn the rioters
um
i don't know the private conversation
she had with
mr trump but i remember when she came to
the office one time with white house
counsel's office
when she came to the chief of staff's
office with white house counsel's office
she was talking about the speech later
that day and trying to
get her dad on board with
saying something that was
more direct than he had wanted to at the
time and throughout the afternoon
and i think mark also got i remember him
getting ivanka involved because it's
like hit ivanka down here because he
thought that would be
important
i don't think jared was there in the
morning but i think he came
later i remember thinking it was
important to get him in there too
and and of course pat philbin you know
was expressing the same things i mean
pat philbin
you know was very as i said i i don't
think there was one of these meetings
where there might have been but for the
most part i remember that both of us
going down together going back getting
on phone calls
he was also very clearly expressing this
view
pat simpoloni and cassidy hutchinson an
aide to chief of staff mark meadows
also told us about the hang mike pence
chance
as you will see mr sipoloni recalled
conversations about those chants in the
west wing but he relied on executive
privilege to maintain confidentiality
over his and others direct
communications with the president
although mr simpoloni was unwilling to
provide more detail
ms hutchison provided more explicit
information filling in those blanks see
that for yourself
wasn't until
mark hung up the phone
handed it back to me i went back to my
desk
a couple minutes later
him and pat came back possibly eric
hirschman too i'm pretty sure eric
hershman was there
but i'm i'm confident it was a path that
was there
um
i remember pat saying something to the
effect of
mark we need to do something more
they're literally calling
for the vice president to be effing hung
and mark had responded something to the
effect of
you heard him pat he thinks mike
deserves that he doesn't think they're
doing anything wrong
to which pat said something
this is nothing crazy
we need to be doing something more
briefly stepped into
mark's office
do you remember any discussion at any
point during the day about rioters at
the capitol chanting canyon monk pence
yes i remember
i remember
hearing that about that yes i don't know
if i observed that myself on tv yet i'm
just curious i understand the feathers
line you've drawn but do you remember
what you can share with us about the
discussion about those
chants to hang my kent's chance
i can tell you my view of that please
my view of that that is outrageous
and for anyone to suggest such a thing
as the vice president of the united
states for people in that crowd to be
chanting that
i thought was terrible
maga certainly stands for making
attorneys get attorneys huh
with respect to your conversations with
mr meadows though did you
specifically erase the concern over the
vice president with him
and how did he respond
i believe i raised a concern about the
vice president and i and i again the
nature of his response without remember
calling exactly was he you know
people were doing all that they could
and what about the president did he
indicate whether i thought the president
was doing what needed to be done to
protect the vice president
in addition mr cipoloni testified that
it would have been feasible as kind
basically hutchinson told the truth it
seems
for president trump to immediately
appear at the podium in the press room
to address the nation
would it have been possible at any
moment for the president to walk down to
the podium in the briefing and
talk to the nation any time between when
you first gave him that advice two
o'clock in 417 when
video statement
would that be possible would have been
possible yes yes
we just heard mr sipoloni say that
president trump could have gone to the
press briefing room to issue a statement
at any moment
to give you a sense of just how easy
that would have been let's take a look
at a map of the west wing
as we saw earlier the president's
private dining room is at the bottom of
the map
the press briefing room is at the top
highlighted in blue and the rose garden
where the president ultimately filmed
his go home video is on the right next
to the oval office and that's
highlighted in green
ms matthews how quickly could the
president have gotten on camera in the
press briefing room to deliver a
statement to the nation
so as you outlined it would take
probably less than 60 seconds from
the oval office dining room over to the
press briefing room and for folks that
might not know the briefing room is the
room that you see the white house press
secretary do briefings from with the
podium and the blue backdrop and
there's a camera that is on in there at
all times and so if the president had
wanted to make a statement
and address the american people he could
have been on camera almost instantly and
conversely the white house press corps
has offices that are located directly
behind the briefing room and so if he
had wanted to make an address from the
oval office we could have assembled the
white house press corps probably in a
matter of minutes to get them into the
oval for him to do an on-camera address
okay thank you other witnesses have
given us their views on that question
for example general keith kellogg told
us that some staff were concerned that a
live appearance by the president
at the microphones at that moment could
actually make matters worse
he told us he recommended against doing
a press conference because during his
four years in the trump administration
quote there wasn't a single clean press
conference we had had
president trump's advisors knew his
state of mind at that moment and they
were worried about what he would say in
unscripted comments i yield to the
gentlewoman i mean it's not untrue trump
would have likely found a way to make it
worse by two o'clock multiple staff
members in the white house recognize
that a serious situation was underway at
the capitol
personally i recall being evacuated from
the house office building where we're
sitting
by
before this time it was due to the
discovery of two pipe bombs in nearby
buildings
ms matthews around the same time you
were watching the violence unfold on
television and social media with
colleagues
including with ben williamson a senior
aide to mark meadows and the acting
director
of communications
you told us that before president trump
sent his next tweet at 2 24
mr williamson got up to go see mr
meadows and you got up to go see kaylee
mcinnady why did you both do that
so
ben and i were watching the coverage
unfold from one of the offices in the
west wing and we both recognized that
the situation was escalating and it was
escalating quickly and that the
president needed to be out there
immediately to tell these people to go
home and condemn the violence that we
were seeing so i told him that i was
going to make that recommendation to
kaylee and he said he was going to make
the same recommendation to the chief of
staff mark meadows
thank you and one of your colleagues in
the press office judd dear told us he
also went to see ms mcaney at that time
let's hear what he said about this
critical period of time right as the
writers were getting into the capital
uh and why did you think it was
necessary
well i mean
it appears that individuals are
storming the
u.s capitol building
they
also appear to be supporters of donald
trump who may have been in attendance at
the rally
[Music]
we're going to need to say something and
did you have a view as to what you
should be saying by the white house
if i recall i
told kaylee that i thought that we
needed to encourage
[Applause]
individuals to stop
to respect law enforcement
and
to go home stop rioting no
although president trump was aware of
the ongoing riot
he did not take any immediate action to
address the lawlessness
instead
at 203 he called rudy giuliani again and
that call lasted for over eight minutes
moments later at 2 13
rioters broke into the capitol itself
one of the proud boys charged with
seditious conspiracy
dominique pizzola used an officer's
shields to smash a window and rioters
flooded into the building
[Music]
[Applause]
big time stuff
[Applause]
why would tourists and antrifa do this
[Music]
as rioters were entering the building
the secret service held vice president
pence in his office right off the senate
chamber for 13 minutes
as they work to clear a safe path to a
secure location
now listen to some of that radio traffic
and see what they were seeing as the
protesters got just feet away from where
the vice president was holding
the building
we need to move now
if we lose uh any more time we may have
we may lose the ability to
leave so if we're going to leave we need
to do it now
they gained access to the second floor
and i've got public about five feet from
me down here below
they are on the second floor moving in
now we may want to consider getting out
and leaving now coffee will we encounter
the people once we make our way repeat
counter any individuals if we made our
way to the to the there's six
officers between us and the people that
are five
to ten feet away from me yeah i am going
down to evaluate go ahead
we have a clear spot if we move quickly
we got smoke you know stairs step by
unknown smoke set down stairs
fighting protesters
is that brown compromise we
have it
insecure
however we will bypass some protesters
that are being contained
there is smoke unknown
what kind of smoke it is
clear we're coming out now all right
make a way
hmm
the president's national security it's
almost ridiculous to call them
protesters and tracking them in real
time
on the screen you can see excerpts from
the chat logs among the national among
the president's national
council national security council staff
at 2 13 the staff learned that the
rioters were kicking in the windows at
the capitol
three minutes later the staff said the
vice president was being pulled
which meant agents evacuated him from
the senate floor
at 2 24 the staff noted that the secret
service agents at the capitol
did not quote
sound good right now
earlier you heard from a security
professional who had been working in the
white house complex on january 6 with
access to relevant information and a
responsibility to report to national
security officials
we asked this person what was meant by
the comment that the secret service
agents did not quote
sound good right now
in the following clip of that testimony
which has been modified to protect the
individual's identity the professional
discusses what they heard
from listening to the incoming radio
traffic that day
okay
that last entry in the stage of service
the capital does not sound good right
now
correct
what does that mean
[Music]
the members of the vp tell at this time
were starting to fear for their own
lives
um there were a lot of there was a lot
yelling
a lot
of um
a lot of very personal calls um over the
radio so
it was disturbing i don't like talking
about it but um
there were calls to um say goodbye to
family members so on so forth it was
getting
for whatever the reason was on the
ground the vp detail thought that this
was about to get very unclean
and
did you hear that over the radio okay
what was the response by the agents who
secret service agents who were there
everybody kept saying you know
at that point it was just reassurances
or
um
[Music]
i think there were discussions of
reinforcements coming but
again it was just chaos they're just
yelling obviously you've conveyed the
disturbing but what
what prompted you to put it into an
entry
as it states their services they're
running out of options
and they're getting nervous
it sounds like we're
that we came very close to
either service having to use legal
options or
or worse like
at that point i don't know is the vp
compromise is the detail kind of like i
don't know
like we didn't have visibility but
if they're screaming and saying things
like say goodbye to the family like the
floor needs to know this is going to on
a whole nother level soon
as this next video shows the rioter's
anger was folk focused primarily
on vice president mike pence
this woman comes up to the side of us
and she says
pence folded
so
it was kind of like okay well
in my mind i was thinking well that's it
you know well my son-in-law
looks at me and he says
i want to go in
what percentage of the crowd is going to
the capitol
100
it is
it is spread like wildfire that pets has
betrayed us and everybody is marching on
the capitol all million of us it's
insane
[Applause]
did people appear angry as you were
walking to the capitol yeah a lot of
people a lot of people seem like they're
very upset
tell us one of the things they were
saying if you recall
oh there was they were saying all time
you know people were screaming all types
of stuff um they're mad that uh
uh vice president pence was gonna accept
the electorals i mean it was i mean it
was a little you could if you could
think it up that's you were hearing it i
believe that uh vice president pence was
going to certify the electoral votes and
or not certify them but i guess that's
just changed correct
and it's a very big disappointment i
think there's several hundred thousand
people here that are very disappointed
president trump did not try to calm his
thousands of disappointed supporters
instead
at almost the same moment violence was
getting completely out of hand
donald trump sent his 224 tweet
the president said
mike pence didn't have the courage to do
what should have been done to protect
our country and our constitution
despite knowing the capital had been
breached and the mob was in the building
president trump called mike pence a
coward and placed all the blame on him
for not stopping the certification
he put a target on his own vice
president's back
mr pottinger and ms matthews when we ask
you about your reaction to seeing the
224 tweet in real time you both use the
same imagery to describe it president
trump was adding fuel to the fire
mr potager you made the decision to
resign after seeing this tweet can you
please tell us why
yes
so that was um
pretty soon after i'd or shortly before
i'd gotten back to the white house i'd
come from offsite
i began to see for the first time those
images on tv of the chaos that was
unfolding at the capitol
one of my aides
handed me a sheet of paper that
contained the tweet that you just read
i
read it and
was quite disturbed by it
i i was disturbed and worried to see
that the president was attacking
uh vice president pence for doing his
constitutional duty so the tweet looked
to me like the opposite of what
what we really needed at that moment
which was a de-escalation
uh and uh that's why
i had said earlier that it looked like
fuel being poured on the fire so that
was the moment that i decided uh that i
was going to resign that that would be
my last day at the white house uh i i
simply didn't want to be associated with
uh uh with the events that were
unfolding on the capitol
thank you and miss matthews what was
your reaction to the president's tweet
about vice president pence
so it was obvious that the situation at
the capitol was violent and escalating
quickly and so i thought that the tweet
about the vice president was the last
thing that was needed in that moment
and i
i remember thinking that
this was going to be bad for him to
tweet this because it was essentially
him giving the green light to these
people telling them that what they were
doing at the steps of the capitol and
entering the capital was okay that they
were justified in their anger and
he shouldn't have been doing that he
should have been telling these people to
go home and to leave and to condemn the
violence that we're seeing and
i'm someone who
has worked with him you know i worked on
the campaign traveled all around the
country going to countless rallies with
him and i've seen the impact that his
words have on his supporters
he
they truly latch on to every word and
every tweet that he says and so i think
that in that moment for him to tweet out
the message about mike pence it was him
pouring gasoline on the fire and making
it much worse
thank you both and let's watch what
others also told us about their
reactions to this tweet
i don't remember when exactly i heard
about that tweet but my reaction to it
is that's a terrible tweet and i
disagreed with the sentiment
and
i thought it was wrong
what was your reaction when you saw that
tweet
extremely unhelpful
why
um
it it wasn't the message that we needed
at at that time
it wasn't going to
um
the the scenes at the u.s capitol were
only getting worse at that point
this was not going to help that
which could start making it worse
certainly miss hutchinson what was your
reaction when you saw this tweet
as a staffer
that works
to always represent the administration
to the best of my ability
and to showcase the good things that he
had done for the country
i remember feeling
frustrated
disappointed
and
really it felt personal i it was really
sad
as an
american i was disgusted
[Music]
it was
unpatriotic it was
un-american we were watching the capitol
building get defaced over a lie
as you will see at 2 26
the vice president had to be evacuated
to safety a second time and came within
40 feet of the rioters
the attack escalated quickly right after
the tweet
[Applause]
come on
[Music]
during this chaos
what did president trump do at that
point
he went back to calling senators to try
to further delay the electoral
while the vice president was being
evacuated from the senate president
trump called senator tommy tupperville
one of his strongest supporters in the
senate
as senator tuberville later recalled he
had to end the call so that he could
evacuate the senate chamber himself
let's listen
he called didn't call my phone called
somebody else and uh they handed it to
me and i basically told him i said mr
president we're not doing much work here
right now because they just took our
vice president out and matter of fact
i'm going to hang up on you
i've got to leave
senator josh hawley also had to flee
earlier that afternoon before the joint
session started he walked across the
east front of the capitol
as you can see in this photo
he raised his fist in solidarity with
the protesters already amassing at the
security gates
we spoke with a capitol police officer
who was out there at the time
she told us that senator senator holly's
jester
riled up the crowd
and it bothered her greatly because he
was doing it in a safe space protected
by the officers and the barriers
later that day senator hawley fled after
those protesters he helped to rile up
stormed the capitol
see for yourself
[Laughter]
oh that's rich
that is rich
think about what we've seen undeniable
violence at the capitol
the vice president being evacuated to
safety by the secret service senators
running through the hallways of the
senate to get away from the mob
as the commander-in-chief president
trump was oath and duty bound to protect
the capital his senior staff understood
that
do you believe jared that the president
has an obligation to
uh ensure a peaceful transfer of power
um yes
and do you think the president has an
obligation to defend uh
all three branches of our government
uh
i believe so
and i assume you also would agree the
president has a particular obligation to
take care that the laws be faithfully
executed
that is one of the president's
obligations correct
no i mean i asked what his duty is
well i mean there's a there's a
constitutional duty
what he has he's the commander-in-chief
and that was the industry
that was my biggest issue with him as
national security adviser
rather than uphold his duty to the
constitution president trump allowed the
mob to achieve the delay that he hoped
would keep him in power
i reserve
the gentlewoman reserves i request that
those in the hearing room remain seated
until the capitol police have escorted
members and witnesses from the room i
now declare the committee in recess for
a period of approximately 10 minutes
all right so the committee now in recess
and uh i mean listen what what have we
learned so far
it's confirmation of things we already
suspected with more evidence and more
corroboration you know cassidy
hutchinson testified and she was
immediately accused without any evidence
that she was lying she was accused of
just making it all up and yet we've got
pat sipoloni corroborating the things
that she said he said and and all of
these things are all
it's confirmation that the witnesses
have
by and large been truthful
where they remember um there were gaps
in what trump did as is being pointed
out in the chat and we're filling in
what those gaps were what was happening
during the seven hour break in the call
log and the three hour four four-hour
break in visitor log well he was mostly
watching fox news with a rotating cast
of characters coming by and saying you
should say something you should do
something you should try to dissuade
these people and donald trump said no i
don't want to do that
that's essentially what it has been
um and in that sense it's relevant as it
helps fill those gaps in
let's take a look at what people are
saying oh we have a lot of uh we've got
a lot of stuff going on nh barrick says
how about pachonomics for the finance
channel yes we will take we will
consider that one we will consider that
one
um let's listen to some voicemails that
have been coming in hi david i agree
with the earlier caller that your
financial show can be this wonderful
thing for the gay community i think you
should call it the jesse lee peterson
show
what the hell
what the hell is that about all right uh
well
hey mr pacman this is thunder from
california once again just a question
uh what is everybody's issue
with trans people i don't understand
like they don't affect
most people's lives most people don't
even know anybody who's trans but
everybody's so concerned about it in the
media let me know your thoughts thank
you sir is it true that most people
don't even know anyone who's trans
that's an interesting question i don't
know the answer to that it's an
empirical question
um
i guess in theory they might not know
that they know someone who's trans also
it's sort of like when people go
uh i never met a jew growing up and it's
like well maybe you just didn't know
that the person was jewish i don't know
um
anyway yeah i mean i don't really
understand
the obsession
um here's another voicemail
hey david uh you know ronda sanchez is
handing out some checks for
several hundred dollars to
offset the inflation
but i thought that that's what caused
inflation according to these republicans
so isn't that just going to cause more
inflation
and then you're going to have to give
out more checks and then more inflation
or something we've we've talked about
that i'm not going to go into that right
now
um
but uh it's certainly a topic
so anyways i was thinking about how like
our morality is set up in a way um where
we agree on
that the individual here in america
is more important than like what your
family did or what you know
uh
like the collaborative
um
vibe man whitney's back but i'm kind of
like tuned out on it um haley from
georgia holly
fist up and then
just out immediately out absolutely
that's exactly what he did tyler says my
dad is a trans woman and is a staunch
republican trans people exist and are
allowed to be people imagine that
imagine that
okay if you're just joining us let me
catch you up on things going on uh
related to the show number one we are
going to be starting a personal finance
channel it will be all personal finance
content it will not be in the news and
politics vertical some people saying
david sir why not just put the personal
finance clips on
your main channel well our main channel
is in the news and politics vertical you
want the content to match the vertical
you're in you want the ads to match the
vertical you're in so if we're
exclusively going to be doing some
personal finance stuff we're going to do
it in its own channel
that's where you come in
what should the channel be called
i will read to you some of the
suggestions that have come in
dollar daddy
the financial show
the price of mangoes
making sense
with david pakman
pack your money
the oranges of finance
from the standpoint of finance
fiscal
therapy
mind your money
dave's dough
those are the ones that have come in so
far
if you have a suggestion for the
personal finance channel email info
davidpakman.com you can skip emailing
pacmoney everybody's thought of that
everybody's thought of that secondly
tuesday next tuesday
july 26th 6 p
east
3p west
is the next town hall
and it'll be live on the pacman live
channel and i hope you'll be there what
if i called the the the channel troth
central yeah that's not a bad idea
um so that'll be tuesday at six i hope
you will join it would be a really
really great thing
now i have to actually do something very
special
um i i didn't even realize this
but youtube now allows the gifting of
memberships and graveborn has gifted a
hundred memberships on youtube
putting us at
6.71
i'm gonna do something we've never ever
ever done before
i'm making the goal 750.
we've never even come close to touching
that
but we're going for it
we're going for it today all right
jennifer suggesting david does finance
justin
suggests troth financial
truth financial
as the name
super chat's coming in truth financial
says stephen somebody else said it
earlier but i like pakonomics
that's an interesting idea
a number of different ideas voicemails
continue to dump in
hey david doug from south dakota
i was thinking about the
2024 election and the republicans it
doesn't really matter who's elected
whoever it is as far as republicans
they're going to pardon trump even if
it's not 2024 what are your thoughts
thanks i don't know that that's true at
all
do not know that that's true at all
um sean is suggesting deepak anomics
new here do we know when bannon will
testify in uh in his trial or here
either way i don't know the answer nancy
i want to say thank you to kevin gouldy
for gifting a subscription at
joinpackman.com
if you are just joining us if you're new
here or if you're just confused um we
are primarily viewer supported i would
love for you to go to my website
joinpacman.com
you have a number of different
memberships available monthly and yearly
we also have coupon codes one coupon
code is indict
should be obvious the meaning given what
we're watching today if you don't like
that one there's another coupon code
obama
that one is actually even more
significant incredible stuff
and uh i've been doing the best i can to
thank absolutely every single person
who've been si who's been signing up uh
and i will continue to do so as we get
ready to reconvene here
in the house hearing room
david makes sense is mike cooper's idea
my new show name suggestion duck gets
with david
that's another idea many many ideas
coming in some of them good
i would even venture to say
let's see if i have any other super
chats for everybody
uh
let's see here
david sir thank you so much for taking
my call and all you do
um real quick so
i'm gonna be flying out to new york in
two weeks
um what is the best bagel order um or
bagel place to go to and also what is
the best bagel order um
in your opinion again thank you so much
for taking my call and uh yeah
okay so it it's hard to say i mean like
there's no one best bagel place in new
york new york's pretty big you know so
the one best bagel but it's like what
place has the best coffee in new york
like okay there's a ton um a couple
different things one
if you're
in manhattan
uh on the lower east side there's a
place called russ and daughters it's not
cheap
there will be a long line
but it's excellent if you like smoked
fish so i would it's it's really a
a critical experience
um if you're kind of in a more you know
neighborhood area although everything's
a neighborhood i don't know a more
acquaint area if you are in the borum
hill area of brooklyn
my stomping grounds i would suggest
smith street bagels and also court
street bagels different style bagels
and i think
i like to typically judge a place by
your sort of standard locks right which
is you've got your smoked salmon
uh cream cheese
plain um scallion cream cheese is fine
chive cream cheese can be good
and a nice nice slice of tomato a little
bit of red onion pickled red onion um
and
capers if you like them drop a little
bit of lemon juice on it
i'm not big on capers personally
but
yeah that's that's usually what i judge
places by
um but it's all it's all up to you
that's that's the great thing about
america you get whatever you want okay
how about a simple name the finance show
maybe
we are primarily confused
david sir i'm surprised the republicans
haven't blamed january 6 on biden fair
what are the odds trump runs again i
think very likely
dave regarding the stats on trans folks
a glad report said 80 of people don't
personally know a trans person critical
for changing hearts and minds all right
well that is that is data if it is
accurate
david sir have you had court street
grocers if so what's your go-to uh
choice of sandwich i have not
i can't say i've had the pleasure
we are almost back erica sends a 20
super chat
the dude says have you seen the 2024
slogan for the cultist trump 24 the
revenge tour i have not seen that
how about dave's two cents not a bad
idea
thanks to tw terry schwerin who has just
gifted a subscription at
joinedpakman.com
over on twitch nothing happening on
twitch we do have a new leader for
lifetime gifted subs it is skittle stew
with
589 gifted subscriptions an incredible
number an incredible accomplishment i
must say
other voicemails let's see if we can
sneak him in
hey david if donald trump
was indicted by the department of
justice then the trial as far as i know
was the
televised because there's no cameras
allowed do you know if there is any way
to allow cameras in because i feel like
that would be yeah basically up to the
judge and i don't remember the rules on
do federal cases never have cameras in
the courtroom i'm trying to remember if
that's a thing i'm sure someone in the
audience would know that are there never
cameras in federal courthouses
i remember this was an issue with a
couple trials we've talked about i
talked about excuse me like michael
cohen's i think
people are saying that that's correct no
cameras in federal courthouses
pacman payola
that's i like that one that's a good one
uh thanks to david king for signing up
at jointpacman.com as well as randy
england
new members 674 and 675. guys we've
never had a number like this ever ever
ever ever
sir if you're looking for a financial
expert i know of a florida billionaire
with ties to new york that's an
interesting guest
deepak there's a competitive dem primary
in manhattan with two damn dinosaurs and
change candidate suraj patel
okay i will look into that
i will look into it i gotta i'm not
following any local races right now
let's listen dice of course the chair
benny thompson out with a coveted a
positive cobia diagnosis we heard him uh
give a statement at the beginning vice
chair liz cheney has gaveled them out i
now recognize the gentleman from
illinois actually let's do the pbs
speech is the gentleman from illinois
we left at the recess just after
president trump's 224 tweet attacking
the vice president
by this time the president had been in
his dining room for an hour
i want you to just think of what you
would have done if you were in his shoes
and had the power to end the violence
you would have immediately and
forcefully told the rioters to stop and
leave
like stop and leave done
as you heard that's exactly what his
senior staff had been urging him to do
but he resisted
and he kept resisting
for another almost two hours
in the meantime all the president did
was post two tweets
one at 238
and the other at 3 13.
one said quote
stay
peaceful
the other said quote remain
peaceful
but the president already knew that the
mob was attacking the police
and had invaded the capitol
neither tweet condemned the violence or
told the mob to leave the capitol and
disperse
to appreciate how obvious it was that
president trump was not meeting this
moment
it's helpful to look at the real-time
reactions of his own son don jr to the
first tweet captured in a series of text
messages with mark meadows right i'll
warn the audience that these messages
contain some strong language
as you can see
don jr's fir don jr first texted mr
meadows at 2 53
he wrote he's got to condemn this [ __ ]
asap
the capitol police tweet is not enough
mr meadows replied i am pushing it hard
i agree
don jr responded
this is one you go to the mattresses on
they will try to [ __ ] his entire legacy
if this on this if it gets worse
here's what don jr told us he meant by
go to the
mattresses oh here we go 258 when you
say that he need that mr meadows needs
to go to the mattresses
on this issue when you say go to the
mattresses what does that mean doesn't
it go to the mat
just a reference for going all in i
think it's a godfather reference
oh my god
sean hannity agreed and he also turned
to mark meadows for help after the
president's second tweet as you can see
mr hannity texted at 3 31 to say trump
needed to deliver a statement to the
nation telling the rioters to leave the
capitol
mr meadows responded that he was quote
on it
don jr and sean hannity were not the
only ones who implored mr meadows to get
the president to speak to the nation and
tell the mob to leave to go home go home
throughout the attack mr meadows
received texts from republican members
of congress
from current and former trump
administration officials for media
personalities oh it is mattresses fair
okay president trump's staff they knew
president trump had to speak publicly
to get the mob to stop
let's look at just a few of these text
messages
fox news personality laura ingram said
the president needs to tell the people
in the capitol to go home
former chief of staff mick mulvaney
urged mark he needs to stop this now
fox news personality brian kilmeade said
please get him on tv
destroying everything that you guys have
accomplished
when we interviewed white house counsel
pat simpoloni he told us that he knew
the president's two tweets were not
enough let's listen to what he said
genius huh i think the question did you
believe that tweet square
anything about your advice to the
president
no i believe more needed to be done
okay
i believed that
a public statement needed to be made
when you
talk about uh
others on the staff thinking more should
be done
or thinking that the president needed to
tell people to go home
who who would you put in that category
well i would put uh
half philman eric hirschman
overall mark
meadows
ivanka
once jared got there jared
uh
general kellogg
i'm probably missing some but listen
kaylee i think was
was there but i don't
dance covino
and who on the staff
did not want people to leave the capitol
on the staff
in the white house how about i
i can't think of anybody just trump you
know
on that day who didn't want people to
get out of the
the capital once
particularly once the violence started
now
i mean
about the president yeah
she said the staff
so i answered no i said in the white
house
oh i'm sorry i apologize i thought you
said who who else on the staff
i don't
this is interesting
i can't reveal communications but
obviously
yep let's pause on that last statement
although pat cipoloni is being careful
about executive privilege
there really is no ambiguity about what
he said
almost everybody wanted president trump
to instruct the mob to disperse
president trump
refused
to understand how inadequate the
president's tweets were let's examine
his 238 tweet in more detail for context
here's what was happening at that time
[Applause]
[Applause]
they broke the glass
[Applause]
[Music]
we were
just told that there has been tear gas
in the rotunda and were being instructed
to each of us get gas masks
we went from a peaceful protest and this
is a very dangerous situation right now
that there are
i'm being told these protesters on the
inside are around both chambers and
there is now tear gas inside the capitol
rotunda in fact members locked in the
house are being instructed to put on
masks
miss matthews after president trump's
tweet about vice president pence you
told us you spoke to uh immediately you
spoke to kaylee mcinanny what did you
tell her and where did she go afterwards
after the tweet about the vice president
i found kaylee and told her that i
thought the president needed to
immediately send out a tweet that
condemned the violence that we are
seeing and that there needed to be a
call to action to tell these people to
leave the capitol and she agreed and
walked over to the oval dining room to
find the president
we interviewed miss mackinnani and
others who who were in the dining room
with the president urging him to put out
a statement
ms matthews miss mcaney told us she came
right back to the press office after
meeting with the president about this
particular tweet what did she tell you
about what happened in that dining room
when she got back she told me that a
tweet had been sent out and i told her
that i thought the tweet did not go far
enough that i thought there needed to be
a call to action and he needed to
condemn the violence and
we were in a room full of people but
people weren't paying attention and so
she looked directly at me and in a hush
tone shared with me that the president
did not want to include any sort of
mention of peace in that tweet and that
it took some convincing on their part
those who were in the room and she said
that there was a back and forth um going
over different phrases to find something
that he was comfortable with
and it wasn't until ivanka trump
suggested the phrase stay peaceful that
he finally agreed to include it
the president resisted
writing stay peaceful in a tweet
he told mark meadows that the writers
were doing what they should be doing and
the writers understood
they were doing what president trump
wanted them to do
president trump's message was heard
clearly by stop the steel organizer ali
alexander
at 2 38 he told another organizer potus
is not ignorant of what his words would
do
rioters storming the capital also heard
president trump's message
in this video you'll see surveillance
footage from the rotunda that shows a
group of oath keepers including jessica
watkins who's been charged with
seditious conspiracy
you'll hear her walkie-talkie
communications with others as they share
intelligence and communicate about
president trump's 238 tweet in real time
again we warn the audience that this
clip also contains strong language
interesting
cnn just said that they evacuated all
members of congress into a safety room
there's no safe place in the united
states for any of these [ __ ]
right now let me tell you
i hope they understand that we are not
joking around
military principle 105
military principle 105 cave means grave
trump just tweeted
please support our capitol police they
are on our side do not harm them
that's saying a lot by what he didn't
say he didn't say not to do anything to
the congressman
well he did not ask him to stand down
he's just said
stand by the capitol police they are on
our side and they are good people so uh
it's getting real down there i got it on
tv and it's uh
it's looking
pretty friggin radical to me
cnn said that trump has egged this on
that he is egging it on and that he is
watching the country burn two weeks
before he leaves office trump is not
leaving office i don't give a [ __ ] what
they say
we are in the meds and we are in the
main dome right now we are rocking it
they're throwing grenades they're
freaking shooting people with paintballs
but we're in here
be safe be safe god bless and godspeed
and keep going
get it jess
do your [ __ ] this is what we [ __ ]
lived up for
everything we [ __ ]
[Applause]
we've now seen how president trump's
supporters reacted to his tweets
mr pottinger you told us that you
considered the tweets sent to this point
to be quote wholly inadequate given the
urgency of the crisis
what in your view would have been needed
yeah i it was insufficient i think what
you could count me among those who was
uh hoping to see an unequivocal
strong statement
uh clearing out the capital telling
people to stand down leave go home
um
i i think that's what
we were hoping for
so something a lot more kind of
definitive and not ambiguous
because he has that power over his folks
miss matthews you told us
about a colleague who said during the
attack that the president should not
condemn the violence can you please tell
us about how that about that moment and
your reaction
yes so a conversation started in the
press office after the president sent
out those two tweets that i deemed were
insufficient
and a colleague suggested that the
president shouldn't condemn the violence
because they thought it would be quote
handing a win to the media if he were to
condemn his supporters
and i disagreed i thought that we should
condemn the violence and condemn it
unequivocally and i thought that he
needed to include a call to action and
to tell these people to go home
and a debate ensued over it and i became
visibly frustrated and my colleagues
were well aware of that and i couldn't
believe that we were arguing over this
in the middle of the west wing talking
about the politics of a tweet being
concerned with handing the media when
when we had just watched all of that
violence unfold at the capitol and so i
motioned up at the tv
and i said
do you think it looks like we're effing
winning because i don't think it does
and i again reiterated that i thought
that the president needed to condemn the
violence because it didn't matter if it
was coming from the left or the right
that you should condemn violence a
hundred percent of the time correct
we've we've heard this evening how
everyone in the president's orbit was
pushing him to do more to tell the mob
to leave the capitol
one of these people one of those people
was republican leader kevin mccarthy
he managed to get the president on the
phone and told him to call off his
supporters
as you will hear the president refused
and so leader mccarthy reached out
for help to ivanka trump who was at the
white house and jared kushner who that
afternoon had just arrived back on a
flight from the middle east
so at some point in the afternoon mr um
mccarthy uh placed a phone call to mr
scovino's desk line and it was
transferred to the president is that
correct
that's generally what i recall okay were
you involved in making that
transferring that call
i i
yes
okay where was the president at the time
that he took that call
he was in the dining room would you
personally reach out to the president
for more support
i've already talked to the president
i called them
i think we need to make a statement
um
make sure that we can calm individuals
down did mr mccarthy indicate that he
had been in touch with president trump
she indicated that
he had some conversation i don't recall
whether it was with the president or
somebody at the white house but i think
he he expressed uh frustration that uh
um
not taking the circumstance as seriously
as they should in that
who's a moment leader about this um and
he said he called donald trump he
finally got through to donald trump and
he said you have got to get on tv you've
got to get on twitter you've got to call
these people off you know what the
president said to him this is as it's
happening he said well kevin these
aren't my people you know these are
these are antifa
and kevin responded and said no they're
your people they literally just came
through my office windows and my staff
are running for cover i mean they're
running for their lives you need to call
them off
and the president's response to kevin to
me was chilling he said well kevin i
guess they're just more upset about the
election uh you know theft than you are
and that's you know you've seen
widespread reports of kevin mccarthy and
the president having a basically a
swearing conversation that's when the
swearing convinced because the president
was basically saying no
i'm okay with this leader mccarthy the
president united states has a briefing
room steps from the oval office it is
the cameras are hot 24 7 as you know why
hasn't he walked down and said that now
i i convey to the president what i think
is best to do and i'm hopeful the
president will do it
and have you spoken with his chief of
staff
i've spoken to the president i've spoken
to other people in there uh into the
white house as well who else reached out
to miss trump that you know of
that afternoon
about the attack on the capitol
i believe at one point mccarthy did
um some i heard my phone ringing turned
the shower off saw was leader mccarthy
who had a good relationship with
he told me he was getting really ugly
over at the capitol and said please you
know anything you could do to help i
would appreciate it
i don't recall specific ass just
anything you could do
again i got the sense that you know they
were they were you know they were scared
they meaning miss leader mccarthy and
people on the hill because of the
violence that he was scared yes
think about that leader mccarthy who was
one of the president's strongest
supporters was scared
and begging for help
president trump turned him down
so he tried to call the president's
children
republican house member mike gallagher
also employed the president to call off
the attack
mr president
you have got to stop this you are the
only person who can call this off
call it off
the election is over
call it off
president-elect joe biden also went live
on tv to demand that president trump
tell the mob to leave
i call on president trump
to go on national television now
to fulfill his oath
and defend the constitution
and demand an end to this siege
there was a desperate scramble for
everyone to get president trump to do
anything
all this occurred
and the president still
did not act
i yielded my friend from
virginia thank you mr kenzinger
president trump finally relented to the
pleas from his staff
his family and from capitol hill for him
to do
something more at 417. 187 minutes more
than three hours after he stopped
speaking at the ellipse
after he stopped speaking to a mob that
he had sent armed to the capitol
that's when he tweeted a video telling
the rioters to go home
while also telling him them that they
were special
and that he loved them
by that time although the violence was
far from over
law enforcement had started to turn the
tide reinforcements were on the way
and elected officials were in secure
locations the writing was already on the
wall the rioters would not succeed
here's what was showing on fox news the
channel the president was watching all
afternoon
back to brett bear with more information
now brett what do you have
our pentagon team jen griffin lucas
tomlinson confirming the defense
department has now mobilized the entire
d.c national guard 1800 troops take
several hours as i was mentioning before
to get them up and running the army
secretary ryan mccarthy is setting up a
headquarters at the fbi you just heard
from david spunt that the fbi is also
sending troops to the capitol
it's no coincidence then that president
trump finally gave in
and went out to the rose garden at 403.
his staff prepared a script for him to
read
but he refused to use it
as you can see on the screen you can see
the script as stamp president has seen
the script said quote i'm asking you to
leave the capital region now and go home
in a peaceful way the president was
urged to stick to this script
but he spoke off the cuff
eric hirschman and nick luna went with
the president to film the message in the
rose garden here we go let's hear what
they had to say and see the never
never-before-seen
raw footage of the president recording
this video this i have to say
ultimately these remarks that we're
looking at here in exhibit 25 were not
the remarks that the president delivered
in the rose garden
do you know why the president decided
not to use these
i don't know sir no i don't i do not
know why
did the president
use any written remarks to your
knowledge or did he just go
off the cuff
to my knowledge it was off the cuff sir
good chase
when you're ready
you tell me when you're ready sir
who's who's behind me
he's gone he's got around we're all
clear now
i know your pain
i know you're hurt
we had a
election let me say
i know you're paying
i know you're hurt
we had an election
that was stolen from us it was a
landslide election and everyone knows it
especially the other side
but you have to go home now
we have to have peace
we have to have law and order we have to
respect our great
people in law and order we don't want
anybody hurt it's a very tough period of
time there's never been a time like this
where
such a thing happened where they could
take it away from all of us from me from
you from our country
this was a fraudulent election
but we can't play into the hands of
these people
we have to have peace
so go home
we love you you're very special
you've seen what happens you see the way
others are treated that are
so bad and so evil i know how you feel
but go home and go home in peace
when i got there basically the president
just had finished uh filming the video
and i think he was basically retiring
for the day was there any discussion
about the president releasing a second
video that day
not that i recall
when when he finished this video i think
everyone was like
days over
and people were pretty drained
we're pretty what drained
uh
but we say day
day over
there were still people in the capital
at that point weren't there
there were people in the capital but i
believe by this stage you know law
enforcement
i'd have to go back and look but i
believe law enforcement was
either there or moving in or going to
take charge
and i just said people were emotionally
drained
by the time that videotape was done
emotionally drained
at the white house
here's what was happening at the same
time at the capitol
we warned the audience that this clip
also contains strong language and
violence
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we need strong angry patriots to help
our boys
[Applause]
while president trump refused to even
lift another finger to help
other leaders honored their oaths and
acted to clear the capital and resume
the joint session for instance here are
never before seen photos and video of
congressional leaders in action during
the attack
the video is a portion of a call they
had at approximately 4 45 with acting
secretary of defense chris miller
we're not going to let these people keep
us from finishing our business so
we need you to get the building cleared
give us the okay so we can go back in
session and finish up the people's
business as soon as possible
mr secretary and senator schumer
some people here in the capitol police
believe it would take us several days to
secure the building do you agree with
that analysis
so what is the earliest thing we could
safely resume
uh our proceedings in the seventh house
chambers the earliest we could safely
resume
uh
here's my assessment
would prefer to uh right now but i need
to be here i would say in this case
we're looking at four to five hours
the vice president also worked the
phones from his own secure evacuation
location including conversations with
acting secretary of defense miller and
other military leaders
well past president trump's 417 video
let's look at some never-before-seen
photographs of the vice president during
this critical time and hear about the
vice president's conversation with
military leaders to secure the capital
and ensure everyone was safe
vice president pence who was two or
three calls with vice president pence he
was very animated and he issued very
explicit
uh
very
direct unambiguous orders
there was no question about that and he
was and and i can get to the exact
quotes i guess from some of our records
somewhere but he was very animated very
direct
very firm
and to secretary miller get the military
down there get the guard down here put
down this
situation
etc
as you heard earlier in the hearing
the president did not call the vice
president or anyone in the military
federal law enforcement or d.c
government
not a single person
but general milley did hear from mark
meadows
the contrast between that call and his
calls with vice president pence tell you
everything you need to know about
president trump's dereliction of duty
let's listen
he said
uh this from memory
he said um
we have we have to kill the narrative
that the vice president is making
all the decisions
we need to establish
the narrative
that
you know that the president is still in
charge and that
things are steady or stable the woods
have said
i immediately interpret that as politics
politics politics
red flag for me personally no action but
i remember distinctly
and
i don't do political narratives hmm
so while president trump and his
advisors were drained
other leaders upheld their oaths to do
the right thing
maybe it was exhausting to get the
president to put out that video
but think about the law enforcement
officers who were attacked by the mob
that day
president trump had summoned them
himself to washington
and what about president trump he
watched tv tweeted called senators to
try to delay the count of electoral
votes called rudy giuliani and argued
with his staff who were insinuating or
who were insisting that he should call
off the attack
ms matthews what was your reaction to
president trump's message to the mob at
417
i was struck by the fact that he chose
to begin the video by pushing the lie
that there was a stolen election
and as the video went on i felt a small
sense of relief because he finally told
these people to go home
but that was immediately followed up by
him saying we love you you're very
special
and that was disturbing to me because
he didn't distinguish between those that
peacefully attended his speech earlier
that day and those that we watched cause
violence at the capitol
instead
he told the people who we had just
watched
storm our nation's capital
with the intent on overthrowing our
democracy
violently attack police officers and
chant heinous things like hang mike
pence we love you you're very special
and
as a spokesperson for him i knew that i
would be asked to defend that and
to me
his refusal to act and call off the mob
that day and his refusal to condemn the
violence
was indefensible and so
i knew that i would be resigning that
evening and so i finished out the work
day went home and called my loved ones
to tell them of my decision
and resigned that evening
thank you
indefensible
let's hear what some of your colleagues
in the press office told us about their
reaction to the same 417 message
i felt like it was
the absolute bare minimum of what could
have been said at that point for
something on camera
what else do you think should have been
said
so
a more forceful a more forceful
dismissal of the violence a more
forceful command to go home a more
forceful
respect for law enforcement even a
comparison
[Music]
to the respect that we have given law
enforcement
as it relates to what was done to them
in the prior summer
and i thought it was important that an
acknowledgement be given to
the u.s capitol building itself
what
it's a symbol of what it means
not only to the people that work there
but
to the american people generally and the
work of congress that by law
needed to be conducted that day
do you wish in hindsight that the
president had asked the protesters to
leave the capitol earlier than he ended
up asking them to do that
of course i would love if the go home
message would have happened earlier in
the day
the president's words matter we know
that many of the rioters were listening
to president trump we heard from one
last week stephen ayers
let's listen to what he had to say about
the 417 message from the president and
see how rioters reacted to the
president's message in real time
when we were there
as soon as that come out everybody
started talking about it and that's it
seemed like it started to disperse
you know some of the
crowd delivering the president's
messages
[Applause]
but just as mr ayers said
police were still fending off the last
throws of the brutal assault as kind of
weird as it is to be like oh he says go
home let's all go home that's weird like
just some guy on a video said go home we
have to remember they're also there
because he told them to be there it's
all crazy that's 601 just one minute
after the city-wide curfew went into
effect he posted his last tweet of the
day
after officers engaged in multiple hours
of hand-to-hand combat with over a
hundred of them sustaining injuries
president trump tweeted at 601 and
justified the violence as a natural
response
to the election
he said quote these are the things and
events that happen when a sacred
landslide victory is so unceremoniously
viciously stripped away from great
patriots who've been badly unfairly
treated for so long
go home with love and peace
remember this day
forever
he called the mob great patriots
he told people to
remember the day
forever
like a show
absolutely
no
remorse
a few minutes later at 6 27 the
president left the dining room and he
went up to the white house residence for
the night
on the screen is the last photograph of
the president that night as he went into
the residence
as he was gathering his things in the
dining room to leave president trump
reflected on the day's events with a
white house employee
this was the same employee
who had met president trump in the oval
office after he returned from the
ellipse
president trump said nothing
to the employee about the attack
he said only quote
mike pence let me down
ms matthews what was your reaction to
president trump's 601 tweet
um at that point i had already made the
decision to resign
and this tweet just further cemented my
decision i thought that january 6 2021
was one of the darkest days in our
nation's history and president trump was
treating it as a celebratory occasion
with that tweet and so it just further
cemented my decision to resign
others agreed with your assessment of
that tweet let's look at what they had
to say
who asked you about this tweet before it
was sent the president
tell us about that conversation
everything that you said and he said to
the best of your recollection sure so um
he said what do you think of this
and i believe i saw the
text message or the on his phone
and i
i remember saying to him
the wording on the first sentence
um
i guess it's one long sentence but uh
the wording on the first sentence
would lead some to believe that
potentially he had something to do with
the events
that happened at the capitol well yeah
what did he say
i don't recall him saying anything in
response to that and i believe that was
in the conversation
did he change anything in light of your
comments no sorry he did not
and what about this
made you think that
someone might perceive
the president having a role in the
violence at the capitol
it was my interpretation of the words i
mean i'm i'm not a
you know i don't write speeches or
anything but the phrase
these are the things
that happen to me sounded
as if
as if culpability was associated with it
to me
i don't think it's a patriotic act to
attack the capital
but i have no idea
how to characterize the
the people other than they
trespassed destroyed property
and uh
assaulted the us capital i think calling
them patriots
uh
let's say a stretch to say the least
is that all it is a stretch or just
flatly wrong
i don't think it's a patriotic act to
attack the us capital
would you call it unpatriotic
criminal
unpatriotic sure what happened at the
capitol
cannot be justified in any form or
fashion it was wrong and it was tragic
and a lot and
and it was a terrible day it was a
terrible day for this country
i thought it was inappropriate
why
uh
to my mind it was a day that should be
remembered in infamy
that wasn't the tenor of
this tweet
despite the violence of the day the
effort to delay the certification
continued
that evening rudy giuliani called
several of president trump's closest
political allies in the hour before the
joint session resumed
representative jim jordan
and senators marsha blackburn tommy
tuberville bill hagerty lindsey graham
josh hawley and ted cruz
we know why mr giuliani was calling them
because at 702 he left a voicemail for
senator tuberville which later became
public let's listen to just the start of
it
senator tuberville or i should say coach
dover called is rudy giuliani
president's lawyer
i'm calling you because i want to
discuss with you
how they're trying to rush this hearing
and how we need you our republican
friends
to try to just slow it down slow down
the testing get these legislations to
get more information to you
mr giuliani
did not even mention the attack on the
capitol
instead he was pushing on behalf of
president trump to get members of
congress to further delay the
certification
even though some members did proceed
with objections
vice president pence and congress stood
firm and successfully concluded the
joint session in the early morning hours
of january 7th
here are some of what members of the
president's party said in the days and
weeks after the attack
there's no question none
that president trump is practically
and morally
responsible
for provoking the events
of the day
no question about it
the people who stormed this building
believed they were acting on the wishes
and instructions
of their president
and having that belief
was a foreseeable consequence
of the growing crescendo
of false statements
conspiracy theories
and reckless hyperbole
which the defeated president kept
shouting into the largest megaphone
on planet earth
the violence
destruction
and chaos we saw earlier was
unacceptable
undemocratic and un-american
it was the saddest day
i've ever had as serving as a member of
this institution
madam speaker today the people's house
was attacked
which is an attack on the republic
itself
there is no excuse for it a woman died
and people need to go to jail
and the president should never
have spun up certain americans to
believe something that simply cannot be
well after three in the morning congress
certified the 2020 election results soon
after this statement by president trump
was posted on dan scavino's twitter
account because the president's account
by now had been suspended
as you can see president trump stuck
with his big lie that the election was
stolen
but he did say there would be an orderly
transition
we learned though that
the statement was not necessarily his
idea
jason miller a campaign advisor told us
that after the joint session started he
heard nothing from president trump or
the white house about assuring the
nation
that the transfer of power would take
place
so mr miller took it upon himself to
draft the statement and call the
president at 9 23 that night to convince
him to put it out let's listen to what
he had to say about the call
did he disagree with something that you
would put in a statement some particular
word or phrase that he did not want
included uh i'd say just a uh
he wanted to say
peaceful transition
and i said that ship's kind of already
sailed so we're going to say orderly
transition
that was that was about the extent of
disagreement or push back from the
conversation
the last person president trump spoke to
by phone that night was johnny mcentee
his head of personnel
mr mcinty told us that they talked about
the events of the day
and the multiple resignation by by
administration officials
the decision whether to resign was one
that weighed heavily on people in the
administration
on the one hand people like mr pottinger
and ms matthews here as proud as they
were to have served refused to be
associated with president trump's
dereliction of duty
but others were sincerely worried that
leaving president trump to his own
devices would put the country at
continued risk
listen to what we heard about that
tension from pat sipoloni from general
mark milley and eugene scalia who was
the secretary of labor
and then
after that
some people were resigning obviously
over january 6 we know who they
they were
did i consider it
yes did i do it no
concerned about as if if
people in the council's office left who
would
who would replace me
and i had some concerns that it might be
somebody who
you know had been giving bad advice on
the morning of the seventh
decision i arrived at was that the most
constructive thing i could think of was
to seek a meeting of the cabinet
you know i
thought that
trying to work within the administration
to steady the ship
was likely to have you know greater
value
um than uh simply resigning
uh after which point would have been um
powerless to uh really affect things
with the administration
she thought that there should be a
cabinet meeting
do you know why i thought it would not
be i i i don't remember why i i think it
probably had something to do with mark's
view of how the president might react
and that he yeah but things like that
now there was a couple of the calls
where
uh
you know meadows
and or pompeo with more meadows
you know how's the president doing like
pompeo might say how's the president
doing
and meadows would say well he's in a
really dark place
but here's one for example
on the seventh
of january so this is a day after right
potus is very emotional and in a bad
place
meadows
as you heard secretary scalia wanted
president trump to convene a cabinet
meeting
he put his request in a memo to the
president and here's what it said
you can see that secretary scalia
recommended that the president quote no
longer publicly question the election
results after wednesday
no one can deny this is harmful yeah
secretary scalia also highlighted the
importance of the public knowing the
president would invoke his cabinet in
decision making and not quote certain
private individuals
though secretary scalia did not say it
he was referring to rudy giuliani and
the rest of the so-called clown car
working with president trump to try to
overturn the election
secretary scalia understood that the
president needed to do more to reassure
the public about the last few weeks of
the trump administration
mr pottinger when you made the decision
to resign
did you walk out of the white house
immediately
now i
wanted to first talk to my immediate
boss that was the national security
adviser robert o'brien
robert o'brien was traveling on the 6th
i reached him at about 4 30 p.m
and told him
that i was submitting my resignation he
accepted the resignation
but he also asked
whether i could stay
until he could get back to the white
house
and uh and i agreed to that we we both
uh wanted to make sure that i was
leaving in a responsible way
uh we still have foreign adversaries to
worry about you know hackers terrorists
nation states
and
i did not want to leave
my chair empty given that i was the top
national security staffer
in the white house
so i ended up staying
at my desk through the night
when robert o'brien arrived back at the
white house the next morning the morning
of the seventh
i debriefed with him
and left for the last time so you and i
both share a passion for national
security of our country can you share
with me what's your view on how january
6 impacted our national security
well when you have a presidential
transition even under the best
circumstances um it is a it's a time of
vulnerability it's a time of
vulnerability
um
for
you know and when you have a contested
election um i i was certainly concerned
that some of our adversaries
would be tempted to probe uh or test
u.s resolve
as an example
in late december
iranian government attacked the u.s
embassy in baghdad they did that using
some of their terrorist proxies
president trump did handle that he he
sent a very clear
warning to the ayatollah and his regime
uh which uh i i think had a had a
useful effect
um i think that we would have handled
other threats of that nature and luckily
no other threats uh
materialized
before the inauguration on the 20th but
our national security was harmed in a
different way by the 6th of january and
that is
that it
um
uh
i i think it emboldened uh our our
enemies by uh
helping give them ammunition to feed a
narrative that our system of government
doesn't work
that the united states uh is in decline
uh
china uh the the
putin regime in russia tehran
they're fond of pushing those kinds of
narratives and by the way they're wrong
the you know we've been hearing for the
entirety of u.s history from kings and
despots that the united states uh is uh
uh is in decline and uh those kings and
despots have been proven wrong every
single time but nonetheless
january 6 helped feed a perception
that i think
emboldens our adversaries
the you know the the other part i i
think is simply our our allies i heard
from a lot of uh friends in europe in
asia allies close friends and supporters
of the united states that they were
concerned
about the health of our democracy
and so i think it's incumbent upon us to
put their minds at ease to put our own
hearts at ease
uh by investigating uh what happened on
the sixth and making sure that it never
happens again look i've always said
democracies are not defined by bad days
they're defined by how they recover from
those bad days and that's what we're
doing here is to bring accountability to
that so we can actually come back even
stronger than when we went into january
6. miss matthews as you left the white
house for the last time that night
january 6
what did you think americans needed to
hear from president trump
i think that the american people needed
to hear and see him publicly commit to a
peaceful or at least orderly transition
of power
in the aftermath of the capital attack
it wasn't just enough for us to ask him
to condemn the violence he needed to
agree that he would peacefully transfer
power over to the incoming
administration because that's one of our
fundamentals and what it means to live
in a democracy and so that evening when
i resigned
the resignation statement that i drafted
i referenced this and i said our nation
needs the peaceful transfer of power in
hopes that it would put some sort of
public pressure on the white house and
president trump to publicly agree to an
orderly transition
thank you i yielded my friend from
virginia
thank you mr kensinger
the staff who remained at the white
house on the morning of january 7th all
right folks that's going to do it for me
i did not realize it was going to go
this long and uh it's a time for baby
duty
that's uh d-u-t-y by the way i want to
make sure everybody's clear on that um
thank you for joining me tons of other
streams that you can watch
and we will debrief from all of it all
of it tomorrow all right thank you for
joining me see everybody very very soon